one of the biggest stories last week was
Stephen Crowder's stop big con
announcement the daily wires response
Candice owes Candace Owens then came on
this show gave her response Stephen
Crowder released a video explaining his
response to their response and now we
have an opportunity to hear Stephen
Crowder's side of everything and this is
an important story a lot of people have
asked me why does this matter it's drama
between media companies and I think the
questions being asked right now could
determine the shape of independent
alternative anti-establishment and
corporate media in general moving
forward is it going to more take the
shape of the traditional Hollywood
System but with better views or is it
going to be a new system that makes sure
the individuals are empowered and can
maintain themselves through the issues
of censorship and run their own
companies after any contracts change
there's a lot of questions here more
than just that and so joining us tonight
to talk about all of this is of course
we've got Stephen Crowder yeah thank you
sir that's a little roomy can is there a
way for me I should have done it before
and I'm an idiot yeah we don't Allen can
do it from his uh the new studio has the
modules where you can control but we're
I also got these vegetables I'm like
hitting the table so if I look like an
idiot it's probably you can lower this
on the right side there's a lever yeah
it's the it's the front lever
I was gonna think I'm super tiny yeah
now you're short I'll adjust your camera
but uh uh uh and also you brought
yourself Gerald Morgan yeah now
officially uh just became CEO in the
last couple of weeks there of us we'll
we'll have to adjust these cameras so
you know Serge uh misses flight I guess
is that what happened uh yeah sounds
like it so we're completely just yeah uh
there you go all right I just split the
difference is that okay I just kind of
went up I don't think you need to adjust
it no it is a turn
it's almost like one of those things
where it's like when Santa met the M M's
yeah seeing you in person
oh right but they're gone no they're
good they have a lesbian Eminem no no
they got rid of it off now just now okay
we're gonna talk about that I suppose
she's a lesbian Eminem that she was so
fat
before we get started because she's
eating other female M M's I'm not saying
lesbians are fat right sugar big bones
eat each other she was big boned all
right let's do this before we get
started head over head over to
timcast.com become a member support our
work uh as a member you're helping us
not just run the company but also with
our cultural Endeavors and the weird
things we do opening a coffee shop we're
gonna have physical locations of course
I did the weird skateboard thing where I
got that company's logo they abandoned
because they were woke and we're gonna
do a lot of fun stuff but as a member
you'll get access to uncensored members
only shows from this podcast Tim Castell
as well as cast Castle uh the Vlog it
tells from the important world and we're
gonna have an uncensored members only
after uh this show as well which will be
up around 11 or so p.m we record that
after we wrap the live portion so if you
want to check out the uncensored version
go to timcast.com become a member don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and uh we also have
lucrutkowski joining us today hey guys
uh today I'm wearing my make America
Florida shirt which you could get on the
best politicalshirts.com because I'm
moving to Florida tomorrow sorry guys
but the daily wire gave me the a deal I
couldn't refuse I'm leaving no no I'm
joking I'm kidding I'm I'm in Arizona
because Carrie Lakes no no no I'm
fiercely fiercely independent I just
launched a new business called I'm the
real og.com so if you're in Florida I
want to link up with me and want to
check out my new business I'm the real
og.com check it out if you're a real
technology we got that domain I know
said it was five dollars the real OG the
real OG no no I'm the real OG though
because it's not a pot shop
therailod.com is like a Spam website so
don't go don't go on that one it like
hacks people's computers oh my gosh
don't go on that one I'm the real og.com
some people by the way can I say one
thing by the way before we do we should
turn Steven's mic up a little bit I was
gonna say because because you're coming
a little bit hot in my ears and when
you're saying OG which I'm really happy
to hear but it was loud so do you want
to maybe bring Steven's headset down a
little and a little and one thing which
camera am I talking into there watching
the live stream on my YouTube channel or
Rumble it's only going to be the first
20 minutes there's really no other way
to reach you like with a post and then
just head over to cast IRL right
youtube.com
if you head over there now if you can
but in 20 minutes it's not gonna be here
or timcast.com we just have it embedded
on the front I'm glad you guys are here
uh the drama personal stuff I'm not
really interested in as much as the
contracts themselves I've been thinking
about this since 2006 seven eight like
I'm similar to You Stephen
can I say Maker Studios yeah I was only
verbally we would hang out me and Ben
Donovan and
um Dan zapinski up in a hotel room
talking about creating a union for web
actors right and it's evolved into now
it never really happened and now I think
now I think there's a technical solution
we don't need to make paperwork
necessarily because I mean I don't like
trusting people with paperwork anyway
personally I mean my problem isn't so
much with with paper itself
you don't like it no my problem isn't so
much papers
I remember I was with maker and then it
kind of morphed into something where you
know the whole idea right was they were
going to help protect you get better
advertising rates and then you know I
said some things like hey you know and
we just we can't be repping you anymore
they turn into Studio something I think
they got purchased was that what it was
there were a couple of them right that
were that were out there
um there was like collab Studios was
that the one that was called I don't
know we'll get to know that out I want
to make sure everybody knows kellen's
here uh what's up everybody it's Kellen
filling in for surge uh let's get
started guys yeah so uh surge misses
flight I guess but uh we're all here and
we're we're stringing together with duct
tape and uh kellen's not duct tape no
he's good yeah he's more alike they're
throwing him to the bus right off the
bat it's that metallic Airline tape oh
that's better yeah okay people see it
and they get scared dog crap
your duct tape
yeah the fancy Airline duct tape I'll
take it reflective all right let's let's
take let's wait go ahead
let's jump into this first story we have
this uh stop bigcon.com yeah louder with
Crowder stop bitcon stay in mug club or
join a new enter your email below so
let's let's get started and talk about
uh from the beginning you uh most people
are familiar with the story I want to
make sure as we get this started I'll
make this I want to make sure there's
important uh contextual understanding
people have asked why it's so important
that and why why is some why is
everybody interested in the story why
have we talked about it so much
first I will say well I'm biased I
worked for big corporations I've run my
own company I have uh this this passion
for how the media companies operate how
I operate my media company my vision for
the future and I know so much about this
it's something I care about when I hear
about it I'm just driven to want to
understand more talk about it share
these ideas but it's more than just that
I just want to make sure that my Bice is
clear it's that I for one have taken
issue with the establishment media The
Establishment the traditional media
systems how they operate with contracts
and so trying to build something
different I see what uh what Crowder
announced and what he's talking about
and I I ideologically agree so this
could this this conversation could
change the shape of how media moves
forward as the corporate media system is
dying firing people laying people off
and an independent ecosystem is emerging
with these these networks which which
form is it going to take it could it
could go completely corporate could go
completely independent it could be a mix
of both but there's a conversation that
is extremely important moving forward so
we're hanging out with Stephen Crowder
and Gerald of course we'll talk about
the business side more I don't really uh
I don't really take care of the finances
as much uh but what's the story here
what's the show well first off let me
let me set something up off the bat I
want to make sure everyone here knows
like I know that you guys have made very
clear that you're monetized on YouTube
because you believe that you can fight
against big Tech by sort of operating to
some degree within the rules but you've
been very transparent about it and so I
don't want you to think that that is at
all the same as what I have a problem
with and uh I mean we can go back to a
few things look it really comes down to
what's right it really comes down to
what the truth is and this isn't it's
been a long time coming Gerald actually
came on a CEO because we're being batted
around so long this is this is years and
years in the making I get the the point
with corporate media the issue that I
have with many in the conservative side
of this fear is uh is the fundamental uh
misleading and dishonesty that's what I
have a problem with and you see that
here as a story took place
um kind of it started right where we
release this video we didn't and it was
just by Design didn't name names because
there could be a Litany of contracts
that are similar to this a lot of them
are often verbal offers we we mentioned
it could have been Fox News probably
wouldn't have knew and and they're the
corporate monolith there's about you
know four or five uh so we have four or
five offers and then there are other
investors that come into the space who
just want to dump in a whole bunch of
money
um you know daily wire here out of
themselves
um and I understand that people saying
well people knew who it was well that's
because some of the people who were
under those contracts said yeah I
recognize those contracts and Candace
said on this show I recognize the terms
from my contract here's the thing
I said this is wrong penalizing
conservatives and I believe this to my
absolute core penalizing conservatives
on behalf of big Tech while taking money
from people who are paying you investing
in you to fight big Tech that is what
they're investing in that is what Mud
Club is investing in that's what
subscribers are investing in while
simultaneously penalizing Services
fundamentally wrong I had that
conversation said look just please give
me your word you're not going to be
doing this with other people who as you
well know when you start in this
industry don't know better immediately
after that right the conversation was
Crowder is making a big deal as a dick
about money right basketball money 50
million dollars a year was the
implication which you know is not true
uh people aren't saying that now that's
not what people have a problem with what
people have a problem with I understand
is you know the idea of a phone call
and now the narrative has shifted to
betrayal of a friend
um that's what people want to say I say
last straw I say this is something that
I've watched experienced for years try
to give every possible out to do the
right thing and have tried to do the
right thing in the way that we run our
own business
um saw the gas flooding the bully
tactics that take place behind the
scenes of other creators and knew it
wouldn't be myself so now the narrative
shifts too how how could you record a
phone call betray a friend hold on a
second
it was just about money it was just this
is just business and now it's hey we're
really good friends well which is it I
mean you have to you kind of have to
pick a Lane right are we good friends
are you sending out a boilerplate
contract that you demand of everybody
according to what they say they have 110
penalties on behalf of big Tech and the
issue with that is that's dishonest the
tactic of the left it's a tactic the
same kind of tactic that you see from
the left of gaslighting where if you let
me ask you this real quick yeah I just
want to clarify you said 110 penalty
yeah you can see the contract right
there if you add them all up so you will
because yeah yeah yeah it's a fair point
yeah yeah yeah and this is the issue it
you know look I made it clear it wasn't
about me it's about other people it's
about this being the fundamental
practice and by the way it's not just
daily wire to be clear this happens in
this incestuous sphere across the board
what would you do this is my question
real quick let me ask just just uh my
concern is if people aren't familiar
with the total context you leave the
blaze or in the process of your Fielding
offers you receive a contract a term
term not a contract which uh people are
semantically predecessor to a contract
but which is basically the terms they're
offering for a contract some people have
argued but the point is yeah they
basically said you will be penalized 25
if you get a strike no if you're
demonetized if you're demonetized then
another 20 if there's a strike then
another 20 I don't remember the numbers
for Facebook for Spotify but there's
also another penalty if your sponsors
get boycotted there's also another
penalty if you don't agree to ten
percent uh if If you deny 10 of the
sponsors which is probably like you we
probably accept one out of five sponsors
but let me just kind of so do this
timeline really quickly for people who
are trying to understand what's going on
it's basically the contract you received
specifically at line terms I don't know
if it matters said YouTube you don't put
something in a term sheet that you don't
want on a contract right no said YouTube
Apple Spotify and face Facebook yeah
specifically if these big tech companies
are upset with you we dock your pay yes
that's an important decision it's not
even dock his pay I want to be very
clear here this is a production house
this is our budget that gets docked
Stephen is not just taking this is not
basketball where you pay Kyrie Irving to
go out and shoot hoops right sure you're
paying an entire team of people to
produce before we get to that before we
get to like the finances yeah
um let me ask you this
if someone publicly was going and by the
way I'm not going to be doing the
personal stuff I'm not going to be
coming in here calling anybody a
right sending out Hatchet people
um I understand why Candice was mad
honestly I understand I understand why
she was I'd probably be mad too so um I
don't think it gives an excuse to go and
talk the way like every girl does who
gets their husband into a fight at a bar
but I understand why she was upset
um if you had the ability of someone's
going out saying hey you're you're a
difficult person who only cares about
the money and uh that you're a and
you had the opportunity to clear it in
because it was verifiably untrue which
now no one is arguing
you doing
how else do would people switch from it
was about a 50 million dollar salary to
oh recording a phone call just James
do we allow when James O'Keefe does it
is it only when corruption is on the
side of the left and here's the issue is
I'll tell you who this hurts the
dishonesty I'm not just saying daily
wire this is really this is about the
entire movement as a whole
there are a lot of practices that go on
and it hurts the sponsors hurts the
creators hurts the viewers hurts the
investors and by investors with us you
know it's entirely Mud Club it's people
who pay to subscribe we don't make a
dime off of YouTube we have it for many
years and it hurts what I if if you
believe what we say we believe the
movement in the country as a whole so
that right there right is fundamentally
this and the gas lining still keeps
taking place Candice Owens on this show
said
um hey we all follow the same guidelines
right we all follow Crowder does too
that's verifiably false now so you can
publicly audit this we've had four
strikes right in the last since May I
think 2021 to October 2022. one was the
Makai Bryant one was a sketch with Alex
Jones that one's guilty one was as
charged one was him uh quoting the CD by
the way none of this will get you in
trouble because you can say this now him
quoting the CDC bringing up the CDC
numbers on flu deaths for children
versus coven we were saying this is an
interesting sign clients right that kova
kills more senior citizens but for some
reason is significantly less lethal to
young people to infants that's science
accepted now so you won't get a strike
but that was one of the strikes the
other was when we had Carrie Lake on in
a gubernatorial election four how many
have taken place from daily wire
you guys zero now here's the thing I'm
not saying it's a badge of honor I'm not
saying that it's a badge of honor to be
suspended if if they came out and said
look look we demand as Jeremy said in
his 55 minute video we demand that all
of our creators follow these rules that
YouTube and Facebook set through
punitive practices in mandating of our
creators to do so and Crowders a little
bit more of a rebel you know what he's
been banned for four times and that's
just that's not the same kind of that's
not a problem the problem is saying that
we all follow the same rules because
here's so that's all publicly verifiable
now I could tell you I could tell you
guys that behind the scenes have had
many conversations with senior YouTube
Executives who say you know we might be
able to get you remonetized if you kind
of play ball like he's got daily wire
and insert other people here I could
tell you that but would you believe me
would have to provide receipts I can
tell you that that takes place that
hurts the creators out there who they
end up you know hitting a glass ceiling
that has set the sandbox that has
mandated their creators the same thing
happens
um with sponsors let me let me ask you a
quick what does that mean play
yeah paraphrasing um
titles subjects not talk about this
subject or not talk about it in this way
yeah uh maybe so often don't use these
words you know maybe change this a
little bit this happens a lot right
behind the scenes and that makes it
impossible for independent content
creators the same thing happens by the
way so that's that's gaslighting that
you see right there we all follow the
same rules it was about money then it's
about a phone call with sponsors
look but if I could ask you did YouTube
reach out to you and say hey do you want
to play ball with us yeah we have
conversations all the time matter of
fact I can tell you that there's here's
the thing I'm not going to be providing
receipts to people who don't want to be
involved right there's a difference
between single party consent State and
wiretapping you don't rope people in who
are victims but if it's someone if it's
an entity that you believe is predatory
that's the difference there are good
people at YouTube there are some good
people there who want but their hands
are tied and guess what everyone else's
hands are tied if you say hey we're all
trying to fight this system that exists
but you're not you're mandating that you
exist within the system only one person
is saying hey you know what if you want
to be monetized and you don't that's
fine and one is saying you have to fit
into this box very important context to
this is uh obviously after you put out
the first video I've talked with a bunch
of my friends and they said
look you know the daily while I was
trying to run a business if he gets if
he gets banned off YouTube how are they
going to sell ads how are they going to
do the sponsorships where his views are
gone yeah and I've seen people tweet all
of Crowder's views come from YouTube
anyway so he'd basically be
unmonetizable if he was banned
and then I point out first of all that's
that's just categorically false yes I'm
true because Rumble exists and he
streamed there for the first time today
and this is an important context the
contract you were offered says Facebook
Apple uh I said YouTube Apple Facebook
Spotify but it didn't mention any of
your views from any other any other
platforms and there's Google podcasts
they get they get views I know the
numbers obviously it's not the same as
an apple but it's interesting to me that
for a lot of people like Dan bongino for
instance had more subscribers on Rumble
than YouTube yeah it's interesting then
that their attitude is if you're banned
from YouTube It's a 20 fee reduction
which you mentioned includes your your
status 25 and then that's right 25 and
then another 20. it's 45 in other words
for us right off the bat and this is the
thing I said like what is this is this
an accident like you know in other words
okay we're good but let's make this but
hold on a second does anyone here does
anyone have a problem do you do you not
believe me when I say we haven't been
monetized on YouTube for three years you
all know all right of course literally
we're not that close zero days or did
you have so what happened is we were
demonet how many years ago then they
yeah and then demonetized again we're
like what happened and they're like yeah
actually no sorry you're demonetized
again I was like well skunked again so
what did we do to get monetized
basically an answer right I want to make
sure this point is made clear for
everybody because this is a very
important part of the argument
um when I heard it if the point is you
can't sell ads or build an audience
because YouTube banned you and that's it
but you're getting 85 or more views on
Rumble the question is why no penalty
for getting banned from Rumble why is
Rumble not a consideration in the
contract at all and why don't they
simply say comparable views instead of
the platform like if for every million
views per day you lose we document I can
answer you that question exactly so what
happens fundamental to the business
model and I was informed of that it is
fundamental in other words there are
plenty of options out there right he can
tell you I get excited when I I walk out
and go hey how many people are tuning in
Live on YouTube how many on Rumble they
go oh it's tips there are more people on
Rumble sure I've been on YouTube for a
long time since 2006 but it doesn't mean
that they don't change right and the
issue is I think it's a great thing to
use these platforms there's a huge
difference by the way you know between
being monetized and being on the
platform yeah but ultimately if we
believe what we say we have to be trying
to get to the point where we know that
fast forward five years you can't speak
the truth on YouTube certainly not if
you want to be monetized but there's
this jockeying for position with people
who they see as competition and the
issue here that I've always made clear
is the locking in of these punitive
contracts that mandate and enforce big
Tech policies and guidelines as a matter
of business and that hurts creators and
the same thing by the way when we're
talking about misleading practices with
sponsors there's no problem right and
this is all publicly verifiable I want
you guys able to audit this so there
don't have to be as many receipts
provided you Market your your channel
right I think we probably have some ads
running right now like Spotify like yeah
if you like this show tune on Spotify
um but there's a big difference we know
that there's a huge problem in our
industry of pay to play now you can do
that that's fine if you want to grow
your numbers but what what is that so
pay-to-play means that you can buy views
right you can pay to play you can run
your video as a pre-roll ad and people
see that number but really A lot of them
are 14 second views Eight Second views
but it still clicks that counter the
closest Apples to Apples comparison that
you could do right now is you could go
out and take like let's say not this
controversy because there's
cross-pollination but Benjamin is a huge
show of course he is but go take some
videos there right now that have a
million plays go month after month take
a bunch of them look at the likes look
at the comments
take videos from my channel it's
comparable Place take them with eight
hundred thousand six hundred thousand
place because we converted them a lot to
rumble look at the likes look at the
comments it's startling because it's a
lot easier to buy plays than it is to
buy likes and comments that's not a
problem well are you saying that the
daily wire is buying views for their
company I'm saying that they run the
videos this happens not just daily wire
to be clear the shop big con is designed
because it's entire industry and what
happens is yes these views get inflated
there's nothing wrong with running ads
to increase the video count the problem
is this
when you when that is used to then go
out and set sponsorship rates and then
this is what happens with creators when
you sit down with sponsors and these are
hard earned dollars right A lot of them
are mid-sized companies you run them on
the show and they say yeah but you know
what
we didn't get our money's worth and this
person is the number one show because
they go out and they say that they have
these numbers and they set what happens
they drop those rates across the board
which hurts everybody or they pull out
all together now you can publicly verify
that that information now I could tell
you guys that I've had conversations
with sponsors that say we're not going
to be running in the conservative space
because it's just not as effective as we
thought it was or you know what we're
going to be pulling out and content
creators who say why am I getting these
low advertising rates here's the issue
if you're some kid and by Kid I mean you
know you could be a 40 year old with a
smaller podcast
let's say you get a quarter million
plays not as big but good numbers let's
say you get half a million places right
good numbers but they're real and you
are a conservative and you're trying to
grow this and then all of a sudden your
content YouTube is saying can't say that
can't do that because of the box that's
being created by all of these companies
in big conservatism and then you're
trying to make it right you're trying to
make it something that is financially
solvent and you can't because sponsors
no longer have faith in this side of the
industry that is something that hurts
those creators and this is something so
the creators are hurt the sponsors are
hurt the viewers are hurt because you
just want to finish this one and then
any questions you have the viewers are
hurt because they feel isolated they
feel like their views are not
represented right they go hold on a
second I'm conservative why are none of
the top people saying whatever it is x y
z and the investors are not only
billionaires in our case it's people who
invest when they sign up for mug Club
they are paying us because they say we
know that you're demonetized we know
that you don't run nearly as many
sponsors or very selective and we think
we are giving you our Dollar in faith
because we think that you are fighting
for us
imagine let me give you one final
parallel world there
um imagine if we left the blaze okay
and this again the issue is that
everyone is demanded to sign these exact
same contracts that's what they said
they've been very very clear about that
it's just business imagine Michael
leaves the Blaze and let's say we come
back two three months okay and we come
back and all of a sudden I don't talk
about vaccines in the way that I used to
all of a sudden I don't talk about
election Integrity like I used to all of
a sudden I don't host Carrie Lake in the
same way that I used to or hosts her at
all and all of a sudden all the parodies
the sketches you know the sweeping epic
like a parody of Saving Private Ryan or
There Will Be Blood or Schindler's List
whatever it is you don't see any change
my mind you don't see any of those
anymore we see four or five libraries
I'd be the definition of a sellout and I
would be selling out the people who paid
for something different only one group
of people here is saying you have to fit
into this box I'm saying you got to let
some people let the freak flag fly I
don't care if you want to be monetized
or not don't lock people and punish them
on behalf of big Tech when you claim
that you are fighting them and it is
everywhere and it's disheartening I'll
tell you a story I think the people who
uh have watched my content consistently
know about this the it was it was called
uh some referred to as ad rights sales
ad rights buying
back in the early 2010s these up and
coming digital media Outlets would sell
the uh rights what what they would do is
they would I'm sorry they would buy the
rights to views
so let's say you're a company called
like
um uh badbehavior.com you know some war
that represents would you pick one that
is clearly going to direct people to
hardcore pornography
Skittles and rainbows website okay and
uh same big okay okay
Bodacious M M's
let's say you're a big brand and you get
about 30 million views per month that's
not going to cut it you can sell a
premium idea there would be these low
tier websites you've seen them before
you'll see an ad and they'll say guess
what this celebrity looks like now you
click it and then it'll say here's
here's the celebrity throughout 25 years
and every photo has 50 ads and you click
next and it loads a new page with 50 ads
what they're doing is harvesting views
right so then this website that nobody
knows the name of right nobody visits
tricks you into collecting a view they
then sell the rights to those views to a
premium Network the premium premium
Network then goes to advertisers and
says our Network gets 200 million views
per month right and if you advertise
with us you you are in that Network and
in reality you can only get 30 but they
bought the rights meanwhile there's
something he's actually getting 10
million views right you know there's
some kid and he doesn't get the same
Advertiser rates because he gets burned
and then those kids drop out do you does
anyone ever wonder why the burnout rate
is so high in this industry there are so
many good people I mean you can go back
to when I was in pjtv in 2009 people who
I worked with good solid people who by
the way had skin in the game who had a
lot to lose and you'll never hear from
them again because they just go I'm out
I'm out they get disenfranchised they
get disenchanted and that's the issue
look it doesn't it doesn't affect me
I'll be fine either way but I we've
always talked about building a bench and
I've always talked about wanting to be
able to pass the torch it's not possible
to do this way and by the way the way
you know this is true is right now I
have said I don't want to do this again
I've been thinking about this for a long
time trying to work behind the scenes
trying to work within the system until I
realize there's just no interest in
doing it that way and then you say okay
is our move this is why we lose
conservatives wonder how what the hell
with the midterms what the hell happened
why do you think why do you think people
like Lindsey Graham like Mitch McConnell
nothing personal against them why do you
think that there are people out there
and you go how do they not get voted out
why do you think these are our our
decisions for for speaker these are our
choices why do you think you constantly
lose because the people who really do
want to be the Vanguard at The Cutting
Edge uh they burn out and they leave
because they can't compete against it
and that's the issue I got to tell you
man I make this point all the time where
I just say
for for all the people who are claiming
I'm a grifter or I only want money and
that I don't really believe the things
I'm fighting for I'm like it would be so
much easier to sell everything shut it
all down and and just buy some
properties rent them out and not have to
worry about any of this take money and
shut up yeah take money and shut up but
it's not about what's easy yeah it's
about what matters yeah and by the way
we want you guys to make money we want
every conservative in this space to run
a profitable business that's what I run
away
able to make as much money as humanly
possible but do it honestly and and just
be honest with people about how you're
going to spend that money as well well
there's the issue too we're talking
about honestly is it just friends or
just business you kind of have to pick
one is it a lash out or is it
premeditated you can't have to pick one
look let's let's go ahead I do want to
talk about the friend versus business
thing but I do want to First jump into a
segment where you can talk about 50
million dollars the big the big
narrative that we're hearing about your
artists not anymore right they changed
it to the phone calls that was the
initial narrative which was a lie that's
a tactic of the left let's do the
context here yeah
you put out a video you mentioned look
at these fees
it's you know I I never mentioned money
outside of what I believe were immoral
penalty fees I never talked you've never
heard me say hey not enough money was
offered that's not what it's about so
when we when we first were watching the
show and we talked about it I said
what's the fee we don't know and then
the daily wise response of course was we
offered this guy 50 million dollars
basketball money basketball money the
response then from detractors and most
people was holy crap and they're
imagining Stephen Crowder in a big
private bank vault diving into a like
when in reality
the 50 million dollars included the
entire budget for your whole staff your
whole production facility every
production you would have done meaning
you've got to pay how many employees you
have about 25 soon to be 30 something
soon to be 30 something now if you want
to do production on a skit we're talking
maybe 30 to 50K depending on the size of
the skit yeah every time I show up to a
change by minus fifty thousand dollars
millions in legal yeah millions millions
of dollars in equipment payroll uh
millions of dollars in taxes that's the
merging it's the merging of what was
that it's theft yes let me just say
wheelhouse I'm I'm on your side on this
one everybody can know my bias the
reason that really bothered me is
because I run a company I know how much
money we make and there are people who
assume that Revenue equals money in your
pocket profit and it's like no no if
they're giving them 50 million dollars
it sounds so wonderful they're assuming
you're dumb they're they're treating the
audience like they're dumb again a lot
of people don't nobody nobody don't
understand this people don't understand
because they're assuming that you won't
go into research look 50 million
basketball money versus 12 million if if
let's say Marvel says I know the new
Thor movie is 200 million dollars is
that Hemsworth's salary it's that simple
of an analogy yeah but the issue here
and I'll let Jill kind of talk about
that more the the issue here is like I
think that these people at Daily wire
they've said that they're very business
savvy they're running a business so are
they very business savvy
um and no are they dumb and don't know
that 12.5 million dollars a year for an
entire production house is what we're
actually looking at or
are they lying when they say it's
basketball money and 50 million dollars
I think Candace owns at one point got up
to like 140 or something on the I don't
know you said you wanted 30 million a
year or 140 and the only reason people
people know that's not true and you've
seen the transcript you ever see me once
say hey it's about more money there was
never an offer sent after I said look
it's a non-starter if you don't change
these these terms and please tell them
that you're not doing this with other
people there was never anything after
that whereas of course the non-starter
is I'm not gonna I can't do five
libraries because we do commercials I
just want to ask one specific question
because a lot of people are bringing
this up and they're accusing you guys of
only exposing them after they turned
down your counter offer is that true or
can you add more information to that
yeah I don't know why they're saying the
timeline that he kind of gave was
completely inaccurate yeah there was
never there was never any counter offer
from us what Stephen said was basically
look guys these are the terms that we
have a problem with right and if this I
don't care what the contract says Dollar
Wise if these terms are in there that's
bad and you need to start again this has
to be pulled out so there was no counter
offer because I'm seeing a lot a lot of
you guys saying there's the agent the
agent I think my agent the first they
sent this term sheet they said well if
you're talking about 100 ownership by
the way in perpetuity forever meaning
and it's a six-year contract with no
option to negotiate they have an option
to extend for two years six years locked
in at that rate and again right how do
you penalize someone for money that they
don't make they're not going to lose
money on you being demonetized now I get
that I'm a special situation but this is
demanded of everybody the big con issue
is something that I've been running up
against and everyone in this industry
knows for many many years they just were
arrogant enough to out themselves and to
put it in writing and to say we know how
to run this business we figured it out
you don't know what you're talking about
and of course you know after that uh um
another last drug was you know then
going and trying to take
take our our social media director and I
only showed you that email because he's
willing for me to show you like whatever
people posted all the time when you have
your ideas stolen and they put more
money money behind it not just mine when
you build someone up and someone else
comes in and says hey we'll offer you
more money they use them for six months
and burn them out I'm sure that's an
accident I'm sure the people at the top
of daily wire didn't know when they
reached out to someone who was not
looking for a job who loudly and proudly
advertises himself as social media
director for letteruth Crowder but I
could tell you that on that phone call
they said we have an entire social media
department where I said I have one guy
Gary and he's awesome
a few days later I do want to dedicate
more to Gary join daily wire well let me
know I know they came and tried to hire
him I wanted for John I want to dedicate
some more time to go starting from
beginning of the context of that story
but I wanted to uh address something
before Luke jumped in the uh I Dare You
Luke yeah how dare you Luke
go to the floor that was a good question
you know I had I want to put attack on
this and um one of the one of the big
things we're hearing is uh a friend you
know that you know you guys were friends
and uh the recording of the phone call
and stuff and I just thinking about the
contract yeah four four-year contract
with an option to renew for two locking
you in at that rate 12.5 including the
entirety of your staff
and it's just business and I'm kind of
like you know I hear that it's not
something friends offer their friends no
is it is it boilerplate we send this to
everybody or is it a friend you know
what it costs to have a lawyer Mark up a
term sheet it ends up being thousands of
dollars especially when it's like hey
look hit select all delete none of this
makes sense this isn't for someone who's
been demon but the problem and that's
one it came down to while you're in that
phone call this I said take me out of it
right this is not the right fit period I
knew that please tell me that these are
not the terms that are demanded
penalties that you are monetized on
YouTube that you remain on Facebook that
you stay in please tell me these are not
the terms that are demanded of everybody
and I said that was those are the last
words he said yeah you know maybe I'll
take it under advisement and then you go
okay all right this is where we are
there's no hope for the movement if we
claim to be fighting big Tech and we
sell out the people who are paying us to
do so and fighting on behalf of big Tech
I'm sorry it is something it's wrong
earlier earlier in the show you
mentioned that uh I think you mentioned
this in the show that you were you were
in Hollywood you were uh doing the
standard Talent route and then you
decided to come out on YouTube as a
conservative and it basically cost you a
lot you you lost your manager
I I don't you don't you don't come off
uh to me as a lot of you know Candace
was on the show and she said he's doing
it for money it's so obvious why can't
people see it and I'm just I'm thinking
about that and I'm like do you believe
that no I don't well they're accusing
you of counter offering but but I
understand that but my first my the
first thing I thought was I'm like
Crowder's already rich you know what I
mean like I understand people are
looking at contracts really like you
think I mean if they want to do if they
want to do personal tax returns and
business tax returns and the charitable
givings we can do that this is this is
uh we can do that again do it through a
third party and seal them because I get
private information we can do that
Gerald will tell you this is again you
know uh people like why why I care about
the subject matter so much running this
business and making lots of money I
often say for a guy like me who growing
up in Chicago and being close to the
bottom of the totem pole as an American
which is great for the rest of the world
I mean if you for the rest America's
awesome right the poorest person is
wealthy compared to everybody else right
but there's a certain point in terms of
having things that I could have ever
wanted and it's a very very low bar
right you know I'm making once once I
got hired by Disney the Disney Fusion
they're paying me 250k I'm staring at
money I have no idea what to do with
right beyond that I'm going to change
the world I'm gonna do everything I can
but this is the thing that dialogue
shifted to money money money money you
heard me say this is wrong and then it's
money money money just a business and
then it's this is wrong money money
money money this is just a business look
it's not just a business and by the way
when you're talking about business find
out what motivates the people you're in
business with I'm not motivated by money
that's not what motivates me if you look
back at the track record in 2009 I it
was because I wanted to see the system
burn meaning as far as the system that
kept conservatives in line and I'm in
the liberal system but then when you
realize that it's on your own side not
motivated by money and by the way don't
leave someone don't leave someone with
nothing to lose you know the easiest
situation is take the money shut up
second easiest is go bet on yourselves
you've seen the numbers that we've given
you there and guess what you make more
money you shut up the the option of say
no and say look this is wrong and speak
out is significantly harder than any of
the other paths the two things I want to
say is uh my point on the money was I
view you in a similar way way that
you're ideologically driven that if you
have the resources to do what you want
to do and you're living comfortably and
taking of your family beyond that I
don't see you as the kind of guy who's
like I don't have an infinity pool and
three Ferraris in my garage so when they
say Crowder is just what's the infinity
pool is that the edge it's where the
edge goes off like and so yeah it looks
like a horizon no idea that sounds nice
yeah I mean I wouldn't mind doing a
sewer that's it right but the question
is if you had the choice between an
infinity pool and a young you know a
talented personality who is going to
help change the shape of this country
for the better yeah I think you're going
to choose the change the shape of this
country for about that's my view of you
100 I had to tell this guy that it was
okay to buy a reasonably priced shotgun
yes I'm not kidding this is this this is
not me like well he is Canadian
we've been friends for a while Stephen
can tell me at any point to go pound
sand right so I'm not kissing up this is
it's just like he's like geyser I want
to buy the shotgun I'm finale yeah
I have the foldable stock yeah is it
basketball money crazy expensive no no
it's not right and so everyone deserves
everyone in America deserves a shotgun a
Benelli too it was two and a half we
were in Texas hold it together and that
you were there when I bought it yeah but
we were we were at a we were to shop out
here Luke said hey you should buy that
it's really great I buy it and then he
goes I want it I want it instead was it
a Benelli and then I was I was pissed
off because I was like I didn't think I
was like I should have bought this and
then he bought it before man I'm like
wait wait wait hold on hold on the whole
argument John was by the way how many
how many people are watching right now
150 000 ish 158 on our Channel 150 58
000. so what what 158 is that a 150
that's just on your channel that's why
we're still streaming on I think second
highest number we've ever done okay I
just found our YouTube alone uh did you
want to say no so no it wasn't really a
point was the Benelli M4 right so what
happened is I really want but they're
not cheap and I was like you know what I
I can't justify buying I should go buy
it online and so I was talking with
Gerald and Johnny Boy Who You Met My
Canadian friend I said okay you know
what if I go into it because you know
they're like unicorns they sell out
right away I said if I go into a gun
store to pick up something up or
something and it happens to be there
that's God telling me he wants me to
have a Benelli M4 and I I went to go
pick up some transfers from from Walther
and lo and behold I see one there just
came in and it's the uh the H2O version
the cerakoted version and I don't think
you're with me but Johnny boy was and I
was like ah you know I I still don't
think I could justify it he said if you
don't pay for it I'm going to buy it uh
and of course I knew that it would be
far more expensive for him so I I bought
it but it took a long time I'm not
really motive but it is a nice shotgun
though I will say yeah occasionally
there are some things we're going to
spend money on oh a tool any tool that
you want to learn something with like a
guitar too you want to get good a really
good tool yeah or like knives like if I
have like there's a huge with steel and
that's okay sorry Tim I know we're
giving you let's let's go I love the
Benelli stuff because I got one I wanted
to make it but I got to make a point
about you said in 2009 you you were like
you realize that the liberal system is
you know holding you back or something
to the effect and then you've actually
realized it's on your side as well yeah
I look over to Luke because Luke's the
guy who's been screaming since 2006 like
the Republican machine is lying to you
all the same the powers that were being
given to the Intel agencies and the
establishment will be used against you
yeah here we are well here's the thing
you're absolutely right and uh let's be
honest right how can you change all that
yourself you're doing the best that you
can right but there's only so much that
you can do the difference is right now
at this point an inflection point
history as it relates to right-wing
conservative media I can do something I
can't change the intelligence agencies
but you know what when I asked Carrie
Lake on the show I say would you disband
the FBI yeah I would boom gone suspended
I can do something about that I can't
change the CIA or the FBI you're
probably more effective with that than I
am I'm an entertainment guy I was a guy
telling jokes in in clubs having beer
bottles thrown at me when I was 17 years
old voicing you know a black bear who
was the best friend of an aardvark when
I was 12 which is clearly derived from
hallucinogenic drugs um I love that show
yeah you know it's funny I had to do the
Kwanzaa rep if everyone would find
something embarrassing for the Christmas
episode and that's when I was 13 years
old and I was like oh Kwanza and I was
like let me look into this I should you
know Daniel Day-Lewis this and uh then I
realized oh it's it's Ron
Everett and he beat them with fire hoses
and soldering irons and then I'm doing
this song for Arthur hey come together
now it's Kwanzaa time and I wanted to
pay worth it what's that point you know
I was under I didn't I was under
contract at 12 years old right you know
so there's not much you can do I still
remember we were called crazy truthers
for for calling this out as rationally
as we did saying hey the National
Security State is going to be turned
around against you and it has but
at that time specifically we had a
discourse that was kind of free and open
we didn't have algorithms people were
able to see important messages and
videos and talking points and content
creators now we're living in a different
age I wanted to kind of get your point
of view some people say you have to keep
pushing the Overton window some people
say you got to keep playing ball Mark
Dice is also in the chat he just is
accusing Ben Shapiro of allegedly paying
135 000 and dollars to boost his
Facebook posts I don't know if that's
true well who cares though he can do
that the the only thing I have is one
the only issue I have is one that's used
and it hurts people because sponsors
drop out because they don't get their
money's worth again I can tell you that
but would those receipts be a betrayal
because this industry fundamentally
needs to change people are investing in
you and in us and in what you're saying
right if you can't say what it is that
you're saying right now let's say if you
send a contact who said yeah but you
know we have a lot of bodies in those in
those systems you're selling out to
people who are supporting you and that's
something that to me is unconscionable
and people can disagree with it but no I
think you're I I think you're absolutely
right so what would be the total
solution I'm I want to get into the the
problem solving like what would you do
if you were the daily wire okay so the
only thing and this is the thing this is
all done right now I don't I'm not
saying that I have all the answers but
the first answer and I've said we won't
talk about this again if someone takes a
pledge alongside me anyone in VidCon
just the only thing that I ask is that
you do not punish conservative content
creators on behalf of big Tech that's it
start with that let's start with that
before we get to everything else right A
lot of times people want the entire
solution just start with that you won't
be penalized 25 if you're demonetized on
YouTube by the people who are supposed
to be fighting for you now let's address
the the the the argument there yeah the
argument they've made is how do why
should we be the ones to lose money if
you're removed from the platform and not
making money and that sounds really
great right it's a partnership that's
what they were talking about they were
trying to pick like a partnership and
put it into contract form or at least in
this you know like a term sheet right
well what it didn't take into account
honestly is what if what if Stephen okay
it's 12 and a half million dollars what
if he's making them 30. what if he's
making them 30 million that's the
starting point yeah what if he's making
them 30 million dollars a year and all
of a sudden instead of making 30 there
you subtract two from that so it's fine
to share in these things when the
expenses come up but when the upside
comes up we're not really in a
partnership anymore
we would be
right there
I thought you were gonna run
like come on okay I had sex with your
wife this is a good point it penalized
you
it's if you get banned you lose X
percent
and no matter how much you're making 45
no matter how much you're making no and
no matter how much you lose yeah yeah if
you lose zero dollars they penalize and
the penalties add up to 110 and they
said in their own video they is demanded
of all creators right that's does anyone
disagree that that's what we said this
is what everyone signs now now here's
the issue with that again you don't put
it in if you don't want that the counter
the Counterpoint Candice said is she
negotiated she hired a lawyer yeah
Stephen Crowder has the resources to
hire a lawyer and red line This sure she
put on her I thought we were good
friends
I figured out why why Candace was so
pissed last night yeah because I figured
it out I'll tell you about this second I
want I want to let's talk about the
friends thing this is actually a really
good point
you recorded
co-ceo of daily wire Jeremy boring on a
phone call he says I thought we were
friends a lot of people have said wow
that that was a mess-up thing to do it
sounds like what you're saying in in the
context we're just talking
they sent you a business contract that
was very bad that penalized you 110 if
all all fees are applied more money than
they would actually pay you and it
didn't take into consideration if you
made them more money it didn't take into
consideration how much money you made
them it didn't take into consideration
if you were banned from Facebook but
Facebook generated no Revenue it still
penalized you that's part of it so
here's what I'm here's what I'm hearing
here's what I'm thinking if the question
is
and and I do have I do have qualms about
recording the the recording but we'll
get into more detail they say you were
you were supposed to be friends why
would you record your friend's phone
call
well that's an interesting point to be
made why would your friend send you a a
very very bad contract that that felt
exploitative and why would a friend not
listen to you when you say take me off
the table it's not a fit there was never
just to be clear there was never another
offer that came through after I said
these are the non-starters the penalties
for big Tech right these the owning of
people's names image likeness their
platforms are in perpetuity long after
they leave I said then we can talk about
the money right they he said they came
in low and I'm sure my my gay Cuban
hardcore right uh right-wing agent came
in high you find that but it's like but
there there can't be any terms without
this once I said that can't happen then
these terms the big Tech penalties
that's when so the talks completely
stopped it was never changed and said of
course all these it's like you saw in
the first video we have to make money
they outright said that fee structure
couldn't be changed yeah there was never
another offer after that I said look
this is a sticking point you have to get
rid of all of these change it and also
you have to we can't do this I'd love to
sit as from one business owner to
another you don't have to do it it this
way right a good example is look and I
feel vulgar talking about numbers
election night okay election night we
had been suspended for having carry Lake
on the entire daily wirecast on YouTube
less than a quarter of the viewers that
we had on Rumble when we crossed streams
their viewership went up 40 that 30 40
000 people that's proof of product that
hey look proof of concept you can do it
off of YouTube you don't have to right I
think you use the platform as long as
you can but you need to start building
Alternatives it is fundamental to the
business model on the right to not
change that and I'll just point out that
we have about a hundred and twenty
thousand more live viewers than we
average with you being here so there's
something I think daily wires got some
creative like a lot of opportunity on
their website because like if all your
back catalog was on daily wire at no
cost anybody and they could go into
daily y login and then I spend 99 cents
on a Crowder video and then that money
gets split between you guys like there's
a lot of technical well there's already
doing over 300 000 subscribers day one
right now
um the the issue here is let's take me
out of it let's say you're starting your
own thing right you're trying to come up
in this movement and the terms are being
set by people on your side behind the
scenes where this is the ball that you
have to play I said did you mean take me
out of it it's not the right foot which
I thought if I don't have a dog in this
fight anymore it won't fall on deaf ears
when I say hey it's about the it's about
the next kid this can't work we can't
have a movement we can't sell our people
out and that's how I view it maybe you
don't they said this is just a business
these are the terms but there are
alternatives you don't have to be
dependent on YouTube or Facebook and you
certainly shouldn't make it fundamental
to your business model when you're
telling people that you're fighting them
something going on for years here's one
not just daily wire to be clear not just
daily wire
pick pick a name in the movement most
likely yes here's my view of it I think
the daily wire does important work good
work uh Candace Owens BLM documentary I
think was good uh what is a woman I
think was was a massive success that
that what has a woman reached people
that I know that aren't political and
that's that's a that's a cultural Force
so I think
I I I I talked with them we had a
meeting I sat down with uh with Jeremy
with a few of the other guys but mostly
with Jeremy Jeremy came on the show
afterwards he said hey if there's
anything ever anything you ever need let
us know thanks for having me on and I
was like I'll hit you up sometime we
talked about doing uh Nashville week
because we wanted to we wanted to try
out our new mobile Studio then we had
you know while we're in the process of
setting this up I said well let's talk I
mean is there a way we can maximize the
effectiveness of our operations you guys
are way bigger than us of course but of
course as an opera there could be an
opportunity that we don't understand
that you do and so we started talking
about a variety of different things yeah
ultimately I it came to potential terms
it came to requirements
I of all the businesses I've ever
negotiated with the the most real in my
opinion was with Jeremy it was like I
was talking to an actual human being who
knew what he meant who explained the
pitfalls the pros and cons look if we do
a deal like this you're right it's going
to suck because of that reason that's
true what do you think and I said I
don't know if that's going to work for
us the joke is I I actually said what if
I want to put up a billboard that says
let's change a fat pig and he was like
you know that's not us like we're not
and I couldn't find one big enough right
but but I said like I'm not literally
gonna do that you know it's I feel it is
kind of crude saying that point but the
point I'm trying to make is that we're
roguish we want to do weird things yeah
the ultimate conclusion was you know I
then there's maybe we can't work
transactionally together and I was like
yeah he's like but we'll do we'll do
other cool stuff sure you know we'll you
know we'll we'll talk with your your
guys on our shows you know we'll have
you on you can come on this will be
really great for everybody and so my
view was like I agree with you on the
contract stuff but why did it really
fall apart why did it completely Fall
Apart
like the deal with in other words what
you're saying is they were saying you
need to be in this box because it's not
about the billboard let's be honest it's
not just about the billboard well the
billboard was the box it was like if I
wanted to do something that was
aggressive and more shocking the
billboard is that point yeah I don't
want to put up a billboard calling list
Cheney a fat pig can I ask you something
yeah did they do the thing where they
said we tried to look at outside capital
for you for the first time at work they
didn't do that they didn't do that
I don't want to I don't want to give up
too much of the details of the
conversation we had of course but I
basically said uh
let's just say I made a big ask of the
biggest asks that if if if what you're
saying you know it has to be this way
then I have a very very big ask and
they're like yeah that's expensive I
don't know if I can do that and I was
like look ultimately what it comes down
to is for those that understand tabletop
RPGs they play Paladin I play Rogue
someone commented in super I don't
understand the reference but let's play
right now do you know someone someone
super chatted they're trying to be
Rebels within the box they're Warriors
of God that's a paladin that basically
think of a stoic monk a knight following
the rules holding a sword saying look
the rules are as such we will do right
to the best of our abilities whereas we
here at timcast are like a bunch of
crackpots in the in the bandits Forest
being like we're gonna do what we want
to do it's like the lost boys out here
it's escape and you see a bunch of
mopeds and I think we're gonna throw a
basketball in my face asked me to play
one of the yellow Banger I did bring it
to the basketball court you did yeah VIP
up the half yeah you know I would agree
with you if here's the problem when you
have a few because it's again this is
not about the daily wire there are a few
few key companies that control what is
permissible in this movement and these
few few key companies are saying this is
the only way I'm saying there could be
many ways it would be one thing if we're
saying hey maybe this way maybe this
other way but now this sort of reeks of
why don't you go and create your own
YouTube why don't you go and create your
own fine billionaire investors to give
you seed money well how do you do that
when then this happens a lot ideas are
stolen and then Millions pumped behind
it to promote it as though it seems
original and then they steal your talent
who you Foster you know you you've
probably had this assistant I've had it
happen with dozens of people the picture
I sent you of people working at her
company there's at least four or five
there who worked for me they were young
other big networks in this space came in
offered them a bunch of money I said
look I'm not going to keep you I give
you a letter recommendation after six
months they come back
so I I wanted to address what you were
just saying about these companies
playing by the rules that's completely
my experience with a lot of these
different companies is that big Tech is
clearly infiltrated by I mean you look
uh Alan bakari I think it was got a hand
got his hands on that Google video where
they were crying that Trump won this is
Google
I love this on my Wikipedia it says Tim
Poole you know maintains that can
there's a bias in big Tech against
conservatives or whatever sure and I'm
like no I don't I read a Gizmodo article
from 2016 that said Facebook was
suspending conservative news I was in
there yeah that's how I met my half
asian lawyer Bill Richmond he read the
article and he was like yeah it's like
the Chris Kyle Foundation Ted Cruz for
president and you uh you need some
representation they they they act like
it was a smear against me that I was
pushing conspiracy theories when I was
literally reading the left news sources
so so anyway
they set these terms these big tech
companies and then what happens is the
leftist organizations Clearly say the
stupidest and craziest things you know
chat GPT the AI bot it was I think Jack
besobic who asked it or he tweeted this
out when asked did Joy read and Rachel
Maddow spread covered misinformation it
says no they didn't and it was like well
they they did literally we know for a
fact they did yes and then it goes out
says well while they acknowledge some
mistakes no no the whole machine is
skewed in that direction what happens
then is Big tech company I shouldn't say
big Tech I'm sorry many of these big
conservative Outlets I shouldn't even
say necessarily conservative Outlets but
many of these many of these companies
are just like we're gonna set the
parameters right here because we're
going to be within the Box we're gonna
be rebels in the Box this is the problem
and I'm finding why I think Candace was
pissed too is that when we refer to
companies doing thing and what happens
is the company is a hologram it doesn't
have any availability or or any ability
to do anything the people so when you're
negotiating for instance it comes out
Stephen Crowder negotiating with the
daily wire quote right and that brings
all these other daily wire employees
into it like they were getting messages
Candace was Michael knows on their chats
and they're like now I'm involved
because it was between you and Jeremy
boring they don't have Ben Shapiro
there's actually four owners to the
Daily wire Ferris Wilkes and Caleb
Robinson owned by bent key Venture so
you're only in negotiation with four
people if we stopped saying YouTube is
doing this we're gonna get a lot more
accurate in the people who's doing it
who's who's using YouTube as a is a
filler yeah I want to know and I also
that leaves out unnecessary collateral
damage yeah but like I said it's like
they send out on YouTube you know they
send out representatives to
conservatives and they're patsies for
the higher-ups but when you you get
coming back to you time and time again
you know if you did what company X if
you did what company meaning big
conservative companies who have meetings
with them as if you did that we might be
able to get you remonetized or at least
not suspended and that's what I mean
this is the thing is there any examples
you could give us about key issues uh
specifically about that yeah anything
relating you know back in the day on
trans issues you know for example we had
a character like we did for a long long
time uh bang was a character that
we did was Bane dark knight series and
all I did was an uprising you know
Arkham Asylum against YouTubers so you
can't do that anymore
um there's one where they said you can't
sell off-site the socialism shirt that
we had which wasn't even on YouTube uh
yeah the the the social elements for
fixture you don't want to know the funny
story about that I've never seen John
laugh so hard was we started selling on
the website because it's socialism is
for figs it's a plan where you may not
like it but people also need to know Che
Guevara executed gays right this is a
guy if when you wear a chick of air
shirt you're wearing a Hitler who was
less successful in being charismatic and
duping people not saying it was
successful I'm saying he was a genocidal
Maniac so of course we're mocking him
YouTube says well you can't do that that
shirt is hate speech it's off the
platform so what we ended up selling at
the Crowder shop was a mystery box
and I get a call from one of the most
senior Executives at YouTube and I go
what do
we know what's in the box
I was like I'm thinking someone in
Silicon Valley is opening it like
and uh so we stopped selling but that's
something that's completely off the
platform but the point is right you need
to be there needs to be someone standing
up to these giant organizations and when
you say like Jeremy said in this video
well you know we've only met with Susan
wacheski once and we were really going
in and defending let's say okay one
second are you the biggest most
influential fastest growing conservative
Network in the world or did you spend
time going in and fighting for the
little gang were completely ineffectual
you can't have both one of those things
is true the inconsistencies are the
issue and that's a tactic of the left
here's like fully expect them to come
out and say this is a lie This Is A Lie
switched the narrative from the phone
call switched in there from the money
now that that's gone probably a Hit List
like the Vox adpocalypse probably get
personal this is why people don't speak
out this is why good people don't run
for office and we shouldn't be doing
that on the right I want to bless you
thank you I want to pull up this uh this
story right here that uh story I want to
look at this email know that you've
you've shown me yeah the daily wire
tried pouching one of your employees and
what would make this significant is if
this happened after yes your
negotiations okay so so after your
channel it's not the first time that
this has happened
after you were talking with the daily
wire about potentially doing a deal they
reach out to your employees and I'm I'm
looking at the email right here saying
that you know they came across the
social media manager hey they got a
great opportunity to join the new
counterculture it says they emailed your
staff and said come work for us instead
right that doesn't not sound like
something a friend would know and the
only reason I'm showing you that is I'm
not going to be showing receipts from
third parties who are who are blameless
victims right Gary said you can show
that he came right to me and said hey
look this came up I said hey they'll
probably offer you more money and I'll
write you a letter of recommendation he
said no I know you guys want to be
monetized
um and uh the issue that took place in
the conversation it might even mean the
one that you saw where I said like
they're like well you know we do have a
social media Department I said well I
got you know we can do it here that was
the one thing that we talked about maybe
splitting I think at some point I said I
have Gary and he's awesome so he was he
was named how long after you did that
call about the term sheet did they send
this email
I don't know the day I know it was
definitely after the talks completely
fell through so here's I mean you
probably have the time about what
happened is there was a week where the
election happened right Rumble uh
because we were banned from YouTube
going into the election which I'm sure
was a chance just happenstance uh and
then
um we did that and I thought I was
really kind of securing the future you
know for my children because I'm like
okay there are other players in this
space people kind of know I'm a free
agent our performance on Election night
is going to be big because last time it
was the biggest selection stream ever
right it was like 16 17 million people
across the platforms we're only doing it
on Rumble so I wanted to do that and I
was really nervous Kate went well then I
did uh two shows at the the Ryman the
original Grand old Opry yeah in
Nashville and some daily wire people
came out and the shows went really well
I mean people need you know eventually
releases special but if people need to
see the Clippers yeah standing out to
both shows and Dave was earned did
fantastically well too and you think
okay you can't do any better Reuben
no no just just me and David yeah yeah
yeah all right no no yeah yeah I guess
yeah I guess he doesn't count himself
with uh Peterson yeah Landau
um and then you gave me that look no no
I was like I was very confused I thought
that there were hallucinogens in here
from right now because that's the first
thing yeah
it wasn't in there yeah
after that we'd had those conversations
about like this these are the sticking
points right and please like we also one
but we got to figure out a better way to
do this because it stifles the movement
after that it was yeah we're not going
to be able to come to any kind of terms
and that was for sure after that
conversation I made one fine yeah one
final play in that called like just prom
take me off the table promise me it
won't touch other people and the
question is
look did you was your understanding when
you invest money when you subscribe was
your understanding that all conservative
Talent out there nearly all
are penalized if they're demonetized was
that your understanding was that your
understanding that then they are
penalized if they are suspended then
they are penalized if they don't take as
many lives was that your understanding
when you were investing and people going
out there and fighting for you because I
know the feedback that I get at these
live shows with thousands of people at
every event and it's not a hard-earned
dollar that I take lightly people feel
powerless they say there's only so much
they can do at least that guy can go out
and fight for me I'd like it to be these
guys and girls and for context too it's
very important these fees pertain to
strikes and Bannings on the major big
Tech platforms right irrespective of
your viewership on the Alternatives
we're all trying our subscribers or
subscribers or sponsors and it's
demonetization too
here's here's an important picture it
should be painted a lot of people are
saying you know Crowder you recorded uh
Jeremy that's not what friends do
they're surprised by it but here's
here's what I'm seeing now and uh you
know putting myself in the middle of
this
you you're always in the middle of it of
course that's what I do right but but
look you you go to the doctor no no now
your term sheet okay you go to the Daily
wire they say here's a term sheet you go
whoa this is crazy hey you can't do this
the daily wire then says all of a sudden
you're not also but a few months later
Crowder register stop VidCon then he
calls and secretly records Jeremy he was
setting us up this email right here
paints a different picture in that you
talked with the daily wire and said
here's our issue here's what we can't do
and they said okay and then sometime
later they try no they said if that's
the issue this is our business model and
you don't know business but then they
try and poach one of your employees one
of your and that could be an accident
but it's not the first time yeah well
but you said you didn't you didn't
mention him by name and Gary yeah
employee poaching is considered
vulture-ish as it is but it is business
and by the way there's a huge difference
between employees reaching out to you in
a company right and you feel that you're
available which is hap which happens
versus going to someone who is clearly
not available who was mentioned by name
saying this guy is awesome and curious
hilarious because he's Russian he was
born and raised in Russia until he was
13 but he seems totally American no
accent but then occasionally you realize
like he'll say something out of context
like I can kill two birds and get stoned
or something that's me
but I'm polish are we raised in Poland
yes okay so there you go no one would
guess so those first few years did you
have those disconnects where people are
like are you not and you're like I I
don't understand whatever first few
years he still does it I still do it all
the time yeah all the time that's the
point I'm trying to make uh the the
picture painted so far was that you all
of a sudden sent this plan to get the
daily wire and they were blindsided by
it but it actually seems like now now
there was a bit of a back and forth in
that you said hey guys I don't like this
then they say well that's a business
then they try to approach one of your
employees then you're like okay this is
it sounds like it's been going on for
years but but everyone in the space
knows it everyone in the space knows it
this is not an issue of they had a
polite conversation with you said we're
sorry we disagree and then you devised a
plan to come after him there was no then
the daily liar comes and tries to poach
an employee then you guys are like these
kind of business practices can't
continue no and it was always about the
terms and it's it's stupid to say that
this was our plan to get subscribers I'm
sorry like I get a little bit pissed off
with this because that means that you
didn't pay any attention at all to mug
Club forever that was us getting in
touch with our subscribers and making
sure that whatever home we went to on
our own with somebody else we were going
to have access to the people that paid
for our content this was not a plan that
was hatched to make sure that we could
write off into freedom and do whatever
the hell we wanted with this really
great email list it would be it would be
the hardest waiting for that we said it
yeah it was clear and you saw the
numbers there it sounds like you guys
are like right on the precipice of
creating your own network or your own
website where people pay you 10 bucks a
month and just get access and I really
don't want to have to do that like
here's the thing right wouldn't you
wouldn't it be great if you could link
arms with the self-professed most
powerful people on our side we're
supposedly fighting for us but the
problem is when they say we have no
interest in doing that you go wait
Austin hold on a second here's the good
news I bring Tidings with great joy we
can get just as many viewers on Rumble
as you can on YouTube and by the way
stay on YouTube but just don't punish
conservatives for being demonetized they
go this is the business we know no one
else does I don't want to start a
network if you guys could counter offer
what would be the things you would
counter offer right now what deal would
you guys take from a big company let's
not just say the daily wire let's just
say there's another company what's your
ideal job can take the problem I would
take a deal I would have taken a deal
that was less money less money and more
honest uh and more freedom and not
penalizing other people he steps in
because I'm like yeah it sounds like a
good money he's like you don't know what
our expenses are gee I'm like I don't
know Gerald you tell me
I got I got a lot of different terms
that you would have to negotiate and
this has been the sticking point from
the very beginning and it kind of goes
back to something that you said about
Candace getting these questions
it is just 100 you you don't start with
these terms in the contract again it was
like oh it's a term sheet negotiate of
course we negotiate I've been doing that
I understand that that is part of the
process that's what you do in these
things but if you're going to start
there and we say hey that's not that's
not something that should be in this
movement and you're like well we're not
coming back to the table by the way
after the Ryman we were expecting them
to come back and have changed that and
made an offer that we could then start
negotiating from
that never happened so so this is the
the term sheet right here I've got it
this is that the uh the first one
yeah that that one that was sent I guess
October 5th it says uh non-binding
confidential it does say only one no no
no I got I got to point out for you for
you uh Stephen uh it says if any of the
major platforms
uh issue a strike you would have the
fear reduced
it gives it gives examples of the major
platforms are uh I'm assuming that's not
limited too
in which case it looks like they're
basically saying what at their
discretion they determine what a major
platform is yes and then so if Twitter
gave you a suspension they'd dock your
fee by 25 even though Twitter's not a
major driver of platformer host right
but you know what the good news is could
have been clarified and put in writing
no and by the way I said that the first
one because that didn't look like the
daily wire one that you're rolling I was
like did you uh somebody else I don't
know it's because I think we did reader
view or some by the way do me a
favor I just need to understand this
because one of the arguments that was
put forth is well this is just a
standard starting point for everybody
okay I don't play those games hold on no
but it's not just it's not just a term
sheet it's not just a term sheet
everybody else that production comes out
of you you knew Stephen well enough to
know that he had his own production team
and therefore the costs would be borne
by him but everything else was just
standard of our our apology we're
leaving it in there because that was one
of the claims that was made this is just
a standard contract you know negotiating
start point of term sheet that we we
always give to everybody it's like yeah
but you knew Stephen well enough to know
he did all of his production but then
you're saying the rest of that it's a
production company it's a production
house right it's everything it's 25
employees it's just disingenuous guys
it's not real well do they do they do
they not know better or is it dishonest
let me ask you this do you really think
I will say this the only thing I've said
about Ben is Ben is brilliant he's one
of the smartest people I've ever known I
don't care what he says okay I still
hope the best for the guy and by the way
for people out there then I know that
they're anti-semitic people I've not
said there's none of this controlled
opposition I 100 believe that Ben
believes what he says even if we
disagree none of that is taking place
the problem is when you demand that
other people fall into line but do you
really believe for a second that Ben
so ignorant that he thinks that's 50
million dollars a year in my pocket
basketball money do you think Ben
believes that he knows better yeah he
said that is it honest yep is that
honest now if someone did that with you
and said Tim pool is a money-grubbing
prick and we offered him in basketball
money and someone came out and called
you a little right and you had and
that literally happened and you had the
ability to say and you and you'd seen
this happen to other people behind the
scenes for years and he said that's not
going to be me you had the ability to
prove that was verifiably false which no
one is arguing
of course
granted
you know I think there's a a tactical
difference between us as well in that I
think you play Warrior and I play Rogue
again over your heads but Ian said
they're going like right right I do have
an original copy of Chrono triggers
yes
he met a girl who grew up on my block
apparently I have her copy from Super
Nintendo like Star Wars Return of the
gym yes
word of English when I knew when she was
young nope she's been holding knives
okay it's crazy small world 30 years my
strategy would have been to to poop on
the contract just being you know totally
transparent and I'm just here but but
but but to bring it back like what would
be the perfect contact what conditions I
want to address
I want to address uh what you were
saying about you know would I prove I'm
wrong if I could I suppose what happened
differently for us was that vitriolic if
it was that vitriolic yeah I didn't
granted did it daily wire added
themselves and they said it was because
people assumed it was them uh
after I had a conversation my
determination uh conversation with the
daily wire my determination was they do
business in a way that I don't agree
with but I like that they're doing
things that have a cultural effect in
the positive thus I'm gonna build my
thing the way I think it's supposed to
be right let them make the things they
make with the people who agree with
being a part of that and hopefully even
if they're not 100 in the right
direction if it's one percent producing
cultural net positive I'll just have to
be the force that pushes it what if it's
80 net negative that's your view right I
I don't know I I think well again I
agree the people who the investors in
our case right there's there are no
other investors right I don't know 100
of my company we've entered into
licensing agreements where people have
temporary ability to monetize the
subscribers and the content they're in
right we still have all the content and
when we uh when we left the blaze we
still have that because there was a
period of time the issue there is what
we're talking about is penalizing people
on behalf of big Tech was that your
impression because that's not the
impression that's given and you know
what there are a lot of things that that
you can get and I really want this to be
done just pledge that we won't penalize
people on behalf of big Tech we can talk
about it hey there are ways to do it
with with Rumble I know you've talked
about a decentralized solution to people
subscribing right and I think yeah
there's good with that there are also
issues because people have so many
different places where they have to pay
right now and they kind of want to get
one portal hopefully there's a way to
figure that out here's what you do as
far as a contract if someone is coming
in this entire production house I've
been having contracts negotiated you
know you said you were in Sag uh 2000 so
I I wasn't since I was 12 years old
uh and had agents negotiating contracts
and term sheets I know what a term sheet
looks like every time we do a live show
by the way I'll be in Louisville
Kentucky February 10th I think we're
adding a show on Thursday you can go buy
tickets on the website every time I do a
live show there's a term sheet and the
term sheet is this is what happens with
live shows okay there's a minimum
guarantee yeah and the minimum guarantee
is no matter five people show up if it's
you know your dad and your aunt Tilly we
pay this and there's a percentage of the
gate and if you want more if you're
willing to bet on yourself right you say
lower that guarantee and take a higher
portion of the game I go in and say
don't give me a guarantee and I'll just
take the gate and they sell their drinks
right they end up making more money
we're giving them less risk what you do
is Luke to answer your question you can
present it if it's a production company
where you want them to incur all of the
risk all of the costs okay you do a REV
split whether it's upside for both sides
or some people want security right we
have 1099s who work at the company with
employees some people want security and
so they become salaried and they get
health insurance they get a 401k you can
ride two options
you can do rev split or you can do an
employee agreement for people who want
to do that in this case they want to do
employee type constraints and again none
of this matters as far as I can't be
clear enough I said take me off the
table here the issue is entirely the
enforcement of bit of punitive practices
through mandate at the most powerful
company but you can do it those ways and
there are there are a million ways to
skin a cat you can make that work and
that's the way that it's done we both
know in the liberal Cesspool that is
Hollywood where everyone is out trying
to screw somebody they still know that
you can't do that they still know that
that's one the decision to remain
monetized rests with the Creator and
always stays there it's not a part of
the model because so you're 51 yes
that's fine unless we fast forward five
years five years from now daily wire is
Undisputed number one five million
subscribers and big Tech turns to switch
would it be better to course correct a
little bit now with a little bit of pain
or would it be better to wait until it's
too late it's better to do it now
because Microsoft could buy daily wire
tomorrow it's very dangerous to
consolidate it's a really good point or
BlackRock BlackRock guy Rumble tomorrow
Rumble is not safe it's it's a private
company that's all centralized company
and here's the one thing that I like
about because look Rumble tweeted out
like hey we offer these non-restrictive
contracts I think was it France right
rumble's a public company think of the
balls it takes where I think it was the
government of France that you have to
start changing content and they said
right when you're a public company and
you tell an entire government fine
that's that's the kind of balls that
people are expecting and these people
and by the way the guy who runs is a
Canadian the CEO he's not he's not even
I don't think he's super conservative he
just sees the writing on the wall why
did those people get it why because he's
been under the I would say tyranny now
when you see someone like Trudeau just
because he does blackface and he can't
throw a jab doesn't mean he's not a
tyrant right people have lived into that
chair and they go we can't let that
happen here so Rumble gets it they tell
France to go fornicate themselves with a
wire brush but the people who who take
money from harder conservative Americans
who are wondering how they can fight
back how they can have a voice don't see
it do they not see it or is it the
business model right you can't that's
what I'm wondering did you feel like
your buddy and then what I mean your
buddy like Jeremy you and Jeremy are
friends or friends or whatever but that
he lowballed he knows your value and he
lowballs you and you're like dude if
you're gonna do that to me I'm taking
I'm going scorched Earth
it wasn't the low ball it wasn't the
Lobo it was it was hey look prompt look
let's just sit down and talk about how
you can do this without mandating
through punitive practices against not
some according to him in his video
all conservative content creators let's
find a different way because there's no
future in this there's a lot of there's
a lot there that's permissible right in
business money I get it yeah lowball
sure
um and and you know that everyone knows
that um but what's really hard to deal
with is there was a period like I talked
about with Gerald note where I was super
depressed
um felt kind of hopeless because this
has been a long time in the making and
you you knock on one door and you have
people you think are on your side you
know no wait this is how it works and
then you because you don't see behind
you know the uh the curtain you hear
that we're fighting back against big
Tech and you see this often you go
oh there's no there's no future here
and the response to this is not right
has always been money money money money
I can't stress it enough so it's not
about the money so what is the future in
your mind then what what needs to be
done
what first needs to be done is people to
mean what they say and if you are taking
money from conservatives out there under
the guys that you're fighting big Tech
start fighting big Tech start
with that okay I don't know about the
and I know that when I say this by the
way they're going to send they're gonna
be four or five Hatchet men coming from
the daily I understand that by the way
have you seen anyone else in these
videos is the first time Gerald's been
here because I'm like look you handle
the finances more than I do it's me it's
two on one it's three on one it's four
on one and gee golly we thought we were
friends and you know what I'm not going
to call anyone a I still I mean
what I said Andrew cleave is one of my
all-time favorite people I think Jordan
Peterson is unbelievable I go to the
wall for that guy think Ben Shapiro is
brilliant never met Candace Owens um
Michael Knowles my experience with him I
don't know him as well I really like him
I like a lot of these people good singer
is he a good singer well he has that
voice I mean Andrew Cleveland he told me
at that voice into like six words like
well teacher on parent teacher
appreciation day I'll give you an apple
and they're like this is how you talk
um and it's it's genuine it's genuine
send it here's the thing keep doing it
if that's what they want
I'm not going to at a certain point my
tolerance will run out so send four send
five certain point don't send anyone you
expect back in one piece but what will
you make right you talked in the
beginning something you're saying
something about
um it's hard for everyone to just pay
all across the board randomly to
different people
like if you want to support a Creator
you're on one website you're on another
website yes yeah yeah so so how would
you it's a subscription fatigue right
you have the same with like Netflix and
Hulu so can I answer your question with
a question to um to crash test dummies
here that doesn't offend you right
it does look like
there you go yeah I love it there's
National Trends what's your question my
question for him is because he said like
this might be a solution you have this
idea or or you're creating an actual
product I don't know all of it yeah but
decentralized way to subscribe to people
because and also people who create get
to keep their subscribers by the way
this isn't daily wire it is industry
standard in the conservative sphere you
don't get to know how many subscribers
you have you don't get to take them with
you which only hurts people who are
paying if you end up leaving you know if
you end up not being with a network
that's industry standard not daily wire
again stop bitcon was not just about
daily wire you don't even know you don't
even get to reach them that is the
standard not just there and you
mentioned before the show and I'm a
little ignorant as to what it is forgive
me you said it's like this decentralized
ability for people to sort of an
anti-patreon is what I think oh yeah it
is just basically doing what patreon
does but without a patreon middleman so
it'd be a piece a software packet that
you download install on your computer
and then you can start uploading videos
through the software packet to rumble as
a server or YouTube as a server okay
unlisted the videos and then people
would go to your website where you have
a front-end hosted with this packet and
they can subscribe 10 bucks a month then
they can see on your website the
unlisted videos from the other sites
it's pretty rudimentary it's what Tim's
using a system like that he's not using
it that doesn't sound rudimentary at all
so that was like chip Douglas with a
remote control
incredibly complicated here's
the idea right now is that you're an
independent Creator yeah you go to
patreon you go to locals yeah you go to
someone else's company you sign up
there's the infrastructure you give them
10 right I've done the math 10 is steep
but they're trying to run a business
have employees so I get it sure so what
we we were talking about this a long
time ago make the software you get your
own server space your cost you get your
own domain your cost you install that
software for free open source and boom
instantly your website is a a clone of a
subscription service website with an
easy to use backend for you that
networks with anyone else who uses it
you can also Blacklist certain sites
from your site if you're like I don't
want my site to recommend this you know
Skittles and rainbows.com
you know very nasty stuff right there so
or or it's just you let the algorithm uh
recommend whatever the recommend like
similar words and phrases so what this
does is if I go to your website and you
want to be included in the network
people will see and this could be bad
for business some people might want to
do it they will see like recommended Tim
cast IRL episode with Stephen Crowder
and be like oh I'd like to watch that
show too creating uh it's so YouTube's
one of the powerful things about YouTube
is that it recommends shows after shows
yeah and that recommendations from my
shows it's Seth Meyers oh wow right yeah
way better than Seth Meyers it's good
this is the point it used to be
legitimate it used to be that if you
watched Crowder you get recommended
similar shows or more Crowder now
they're driving everyone away right and
so they're taking away the natural uh
networking marketing value so our idea
was create it decentralized no one gets
a cut of your money that's your business
you got to spend money on your bandwidth
that's your business
but it's free open source and it rips it
rips away from the centralization and
creates so I really like that now here's
the one thing too that Gerald kind of
knows is
um what's always been true north to me
is the viewer right as a person watching
is how do they get the most value for
their money
and there are so many places to
subscribe right now it's too fragmented
yes and I under but I also understand
the danger of a centralized power right
but if there would be a way for kind of
like you were talking about with maker
for there to be an alliance where maybe
there's some kind of a price break or
discount if you get to subscribe to
these other creators right so that you
don't have to do six dollars on a
patreon here five dollars you know on
locals here and by the way nothing wrong
with it I'm just saying people feel like
there's this payment fatigue the
subscription fatigue if we want to fight
the Left Right think about just what
they call the stream with Batista's in
this like canoe uh time I like Disney
ESPN and uh what is it Disney and Hulu
right that's a value added and I think
this is what was so disheartening is was
really hoping that we could do that and
the conservative movement where people
can kind of get access to a portal and
support the people that they want to uh
I don't know that it's possible
um but if there would be a way for the
view because for the viewer what's ideal
is to be able to get access to more
people that they want rather than having
it because the price adds up right now
it's hard it's like 10 bucks for Tim 10
bucks for you with this Tech that I'm
building uh we haven't had the multi
subscription system set up but you could
do something where it's like 10 for him
10 for you or 18 for both of you then
you each get nine but you'll eventually
have to take some sort of lost discount
if you're going to run a packet
otherwise it would just be right it's
hard to figure out that right yeah it is
it's tough to figure it out
um but there are ways to do it obviously
people on the left have done it to some
degree
um the worst thing that I will say the
thing that really is YouTube is it
YouTube red or YouTube premium what are
they premium yeah I tell you what though
you know what sucks about it that's
actually a really good deal you get
YouTube music which replaces Spotify you
get YouTube TV which replaces cable and
sling and you get HBO Max you're like
but they're subsidized yes yes they are
obsessed with nice but guess what
so are these companies on the right all
right but they're subsidizing it in a
way that is not foundationally sound for
a move forward let me tell you something
that really I feel like this should
require hallucinogens I'm so happy too
if you're interested
let me let me let me tell you guys
something that that is kind of crazy to
me
and people don't believe
there are no investors in timcast there
are only there's only me as the
principal of the entire company Soul
owner sole board member president CEO
Treasurer chairman et cetera et cetera
et cetera their staff you know I have a
CEO we have we've got people who work
here but I own literally all of it
control all of it with no outside
investment it's literally just I started
making you're not even Jewish yeah I'm
I'm uh I'm just saying to the
anti-semites by the way we're not
talking about no one talking about is
even Jewish that's a point I make all
the time there are people who have been
successful in media who aren't I don't
know why they have that conspiracy
belief but my it was shocking for me to
find out that these these big
alternatives
only exist because some powerful
industrialist or billionaire decided I'm
going to spend money but that that money
comes with their influence now the only
issue I have with that is that we don't
know what their influence is and you oh
if right if you come to timcast.com you
know the whole influence in driving
force behind this is literally just me
if you're a customer here as a member or
whatever you're supporting us it is
literally me in charge of everything but
a lot of these other companies you don't
know who who's behind the scenes putting
money in and saying hey guys I want to
see this
I understand how businesses work I
understand investment works but you
won't know and if you knew it's ball
retractingly terrifying I mean that
there's some information again that
you're not going to open third prize
it's probably going to be coming out in
the next six months year that will shock
people startle people I could tell you
that but would have to provide receipts
and would that be a betrayal that's the
issue right I've given you a lot of
information that you can publicly audit
and I think that's important I'm not
going to pull people in like I said Gary
said you can use it I can't show you the
three four five other instances just in
the last two years where that's happened
it is absolutely terrifying but what was
the crazy idea you were saying I thought
you were like I thought you were gonna
like I thought you just came up with a
business plan or something oh it's it's
just I think it's crazy to me that's not
so crazy that's totally reasonable I
guess that's why I'm throwing no no no
what's crazy to me is that we've gone to
the point we have without that when it
seems when seemingly no one else does
it's really but here's what I want to
say Stephen really I'm looking I'm
looking at I don't think it's really to
have the website rolling with Subs oh no
we've had a lot of offers too from
people who like run these sort of credit
card processing these platforms are
offering to give us better rates as well
so there are a lot of people who've come
forward uh like I said I mean daily it's
not about daily wire wasn't even the
highest offer just but here's what I
want to say yeah I'm going to say this
right in in front of every every single
person I think you're going to make a
hundred million dollars a year yeah I
think you're absolutely insane I think I
I think I'm right but I would never
demand that just to be clear setting
from yeah did I tell you my new job yes
for crying out loud I you're trying to
you're trying to give him a heart attack
I I I've seen your numbers
I know look we've got 175 000 people
watching on a show that normally gets 40
40 to 45 000. 130 000 live viewers
tripling quadrupling quadrupling the
live viewership we get because you came
to talk about something that's important
to you you have people who are not only
fans of your content who are entertained
by it but also believe in you looking at
your mug club numbers
I think you launched this thing you
maybe maybe not look it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna snowball rolling down a
hill I think you launched this thing and
you're making three to five million per
month right off the get-go by the way I
mean the whole production company whole
production company which your staff is
working on their budgets I'm gonna fork
in the road which is you know a lot of
money for bandwidth you're gonna get a
lot of people to sign up I could walk
away and I understand this isn't lost on
me the only way people will 100 believe
what I say and that there's no ulterior
motive which is what I try to do in the
negotiations like take me off the table
this is why this is a sticking point is
if I walk away from this forever
is if I never monetize again and I just
go back off into the sunset just you
know do stand up maybe do a once a week
show something like that so I can
continue selling out the the venues and
I could do that and general knows that I
strongly consider that at one point
and I think he was the one if I'm not
saying he said like yeah but then if you
do that then this will just all blow
over in two months and it'll be the same
problem so I do I get I get the question
of authenticity again but I would ask
you if this is the easy decision if this
is the easy route to make uh route to
take could have just taken the money
shut up could have gone off and I don't
think it's 100 million I think you're
absolutely insane no I'm not yeah I
think he slipped you nope nope no look
we we know what the daily wires
subscriber numbers they have what a
million paying subscribers they it's
it's between seven and thirteen dollars
per month to be a member there we
they've talked about their yearly
revenues
thirteen dollars okay for their video
content I believe it's 13. they run some
promos and stuff like that but yeah yeah
different teams and it's like you know
look I think let's Luke wants to talk
about the IRS
and I've seen Maxwell's Kindle I'm I'm
saying for one the easy route for you
would have absolutely been sign the deal
take the money and shut up let everyone
else worry about all the problems and go
sit on the beach of the coconut and just
do the bare minimum yeah but I think if
you go the hard way which running a
company especially with I think the size
of memberships you're gonna have is
going to be
very difficult and time consuming but
just you know make Gerald do all the
harm
if we continue down this route then
there's got to be other people right we
have to have other shows on there I
could have again just gone off and done
it and just kept my club but I said like
look either I'm gonna leave at this
point or we can't just complain and
we have to do it better and that's
kind of where we are and by the way we
still haven't decided what it is that
we're going it's it's a tough decision
to make I own 100 of mug Club always
have uh we did the mud Clipper so we now
know how many people are out there you
know we were really clear we're like do
not go to monthly forever unless you are
currently in my club we're gonna snap
and be double capture double opt-in
called the list so we know like don't go
and is it a newsletter no there you go
nothing any updates only when and where
and if mug Club returns and this is a
little bit of the Young Frankenstein
oval team nothing let me ask you let me
yeah
do you think that
when you you are going to launch
something independent it's going to be
mug Club but then you're going to add on
shows do you think you'll be bigger than
the daily wire
uh I don't care no no real question
based on your memberships uh based on
the amount of views you get do you think
you will be bigger than that I'm not
saying it says it would it would if if I
decided that I uh let me answer it this
way I've wanted to be done with this by
the time I'm 40 as far as hosting the
show on air the last thing you want to
do is overstay your welcome and then
move to a you know um I wouldn't say
like necessarily uh like a harvey
weinsteer like a brookheimer but more
like a Suge Knight you know how old are
you now uh 35. okay so um and I want to
be able to pass that toward when's your
birthday July July okay yeah so um I
want to be able to pass that torch right
now there is no ability to because you
now realize there's no ability for
people to come up and do
it would be really hard for you to do
what you do now today you know that
right yeah and harder and harder and
it'd be harder it'd be impossible for
someone to do what I do I don't want to
pull the ladder up behind me so I want
to be able to move into a production
role but really what motivates me is
being able to pass that mantle and make
a difference I guarantee you if we were
to do it it'd be within Striking
Distance of the big boys
um which I'd be fine with but as long as
we do something that we believe in and I
I promise we will never demand people's
YouTube monetization We will never
punish them if they are not uh and it
has to be something fair and it has to
be us not shortchanging the investor
meaning the people mug Club it's
entirely independent paying us for to
fight for what they believe whatever
those numbers are I'd accept them I'll
tell you my my prediction which who
knows could be worthless
hit me you you launch uh Subscription
Service independent mug Club you get 300
000 hard sign ups at 10 or more per
month I mean it was 10 bucks a month for
for a lot of people it's going up
because of inflation because you know
people need raises and things like that
but let's say you did 10 bucks a month
you're looking at like 3 million in
memberships with no ad reads at all
let's say you do programmatic reads on
the podcast version meaning you Steven
never read a single ad then you're
looking at another based on your traffic
I'd estimate another two to five million
dollars per uh per year not per month so
right off the bat you're looking at 40
million dollars per year then here's
what happens Steven Crowder then offers
big players
really good contracts no BS no fees none
of that out the gate it's a legitimately
good contract that gives your business a
small cut but gives them the Lion's
Share for the work they produce they're
going to say oh I'm signing with with
mug club that the terms were incredible
I mean Crowder's gonna make money off
the deal the company is going to grow
the giraffes with the hats that's right
I'm getting a lot of money then what's
going to happen is it's going to make it
very difficult for the big con these
other big conservative companies to sign
these deals when a young Trader says I
appreciate the offer it's tempting but
Crowders offering me twice the money
with no with no setbacks yeah I would
really really like it real genuinely and
Gerald knows this if there's someone
else in the space who handles that
because because I'm not a business guy
I'm not a business guy I'm a guy who out
punted his coverage right you can go
back and watch with a blue bed sheet who
is doing stand-up comedy and acting and
then had kind of put had my back up
against the wall right I would really
like it if there was someone else who
already has the money who already has
that ability to do it if they can't okay
I'll carry that torch but
well I don't know maybe there's someone
out there are there enough good men and
enough people left because that's that's
not the best use of my time like it
takes a lot of time to do a Good Will
Hunting do you have any idea how hard it
is to make Schindler's List funny when
you're doing a parody you know what I
mean uh like it's a lot of work that's
where my time is better and that's where
the time by the way of all the creators
is best spent yeah but instead they're
being forced to make this decision you
know you're a creative type you want to
deal with numbers and back-end business
it's exhausting yeah I have to do it I
know I don't want to do it I have to so
I'm building this technology but like
boring that's what Jeremy boring why you
have to do it why because we need a new
subscription service for creators it
shouldn't fall upon you though I have
two questions yeah let's do it exactly
exactly if not you if not me who if not
now when that's this let me shout out to
Phillip Fisher the guy building this
stuff pure genius I'll introduce you to
him soon and I will say and I will say
to everybody listening it's you it will
only ever be you when you see a burning
building you think who's gonna call all
this in no no no one's going to call it
it's gonna be you right I once watched
uh when I was 16 years old I saw an old
lady at a bus stop flip over land on her
back and I paused and said I have no
idea what to do what is happening I look
around and I'm like I gotta figure this
one out and I ran full speed into a
building and just screamed call 9-1-1 on
ladies hurt there's nobody else you
could you can't sit back and just cross
your fingers and hope someone else will
take care of the problem right yeah you
got to be the hero of your own story I
just wanted to ask I actually feel
terrible I just wanted to ask two quick
questions for you guys one would you
guys would you guys be open to doing
like competitions or contests for new
talent and a lot of people are asking
about not gay Jared in the in the
comment section can you guys clear up
what's happening in that situation some
people are saying that there's an NDA uh
yeah well that's the thing I think
Candace brought up right again yeah
there's a difference between roping in
third parties versus single party
consent I think he tweeted out what
happened where he left right not gay
Jared he tweeted out that he left it was
his own decision
um we did a whole send-off with him in a
video montage you know this works with
like conspiracies and sometimes look
there's a also a middle ground where
there's for example like what is the
email by the way if people are talking
about shows I think it's creators yeah
creators so that's actually not a bad
idea contest if we do you know but the
reason I didn't want to do it is because
I didn't want to think that's like hey
this is why we're doing this right now
um but we do have a place where people
can reach out the challenge is like
there's completely controlling contracts
right that own your name image likeness
and your platforms that you've already
built in perpetuity okay that's an
extreme example that's big con then you
have people who are like hey I have no
experience I've never done a show but I
really think I could do it well if you
give me money that's a situation where
you'd be incurring all the risk there is
a middle ground and I think what needs
to happen
is if we I'm not going to be in the
business of just creating shows from the
ground up but there are people out there
who say hey look I have a channel that's
doing relatively well I keep hitting the
ceiling that is YouTube saying we need
to play this kind of ball I'm suffering
from the advertising rate to the
sponsorship rates dropping across the
board and I can just be you know the
gasoline on that fire to back them up
really why would you sign with a network
if you're if they're not if they don't
have your back that's the only reason to
otherwise be independent right what is
the upside at that point that's all we
want to be and whatever subscribers you
generate you keep that's the only way I
would be able to do it it's really
publicity these big networks get get
their faces seen But if you can do it
without that but is there is there an
NDA that's what people are asking is
there any is to everyone just like uh
here right to send a waiver when I can
yeah you come into our studio because I
mean standard business practice Yeah you
can you can't come and you can't come in
and tell people where the studio is yes
of course yeah if only for location it
would be worth it yeah also because he
walks around the pants half the time we
have ndas
um
because we work on projects and in order
it's it's really really complicated one
of the simplest reasons is like we don't
want you leaking information about us
location is a good and obvious thing but
also projects we're working on cost a
lot of money to do preliminary research
if someone then says
goes to a competitor or any other Media
company says here is what you know Tim
Cass is working on all their stuff it
just completely destroys the entire
attempt things like that of course and
you have people stealing you know
creative content right I mean that
happens anyway this is the most common
thing that happens right the big boys
they go oh that really works hey let's
do exactly that put 25 million dollars
behind it just to promote it now it's
ours
perpetuity Clauses really quick before
we go to super chats because you brought
them up a couple times yeah yeah dog
nasty and need to be removed immediately
from Modern entertainment contracts
Because deep fakes they're going to be
able to take someone's perpetuity face
deep fake it to make it look real and
have it say stuff that the person
doesn't agree with by the time I'm dead
and you're going to my Mausoleum I'm
going to be Hawking Black Rifle
coffee
Lord prevent it let's go to super chats
we're going to read from you guys a lot
of questions for uh for Crowder and
stuff like that and um
you can't go together you can't cross
streams there's all there's multiple
bathrooms here
but I mean look if you guys want to go
together I I have no issue with that no
I know yeah promoted by YouTube now all
right that's right that's right all
right all right Co-op the rainbow from
God after Noah smash the like button
become a member at timcast.com we're
going to record the uncensored portion
once we wrap up the live portion which I
can only imagine would be a lot crazier
but we're gonna read some of these super
chats we have uh from Bren Ben remember
guys everyone agrees that you need a
shotgun even Biden is pro firing two
blasts outside the house please the love
of God do not fire a shotgun into the
air like highly illegal yeah seriously
yeah I can't believe he Biden incited
violence he he he incited people to
commit crimes yeah you just want you
could shoot it into the ground don't do
that either but that's the better of the
two options he thinks it's like Elmer
Fudd Runner like like by the way just
it's the sillies in that that show I
mean sorry that shell that whatever it
is whether it's buck shot or whether
it's a slug has to come down at some
point
Aurora Isabella says Stephen is so hot
well she's she's nearsighted
or whichever part would make I mean I'm
sitting next here to Gerald by the way
it's a little scary like how Giants uh
it's a land of Gerald and then you saw
Kevin there downstairs my friend he's
just like he's like really we have a lot
of big people we just went to a Japanese
restaurant here nearby like a Japanese
Steakhouse yeah and all the reviews were
like the food is great the service is
terrible we couldn't all fit in a booth
it was difficult you're at that point
when everything's like to be custom this
has been my whole life I know I'm kind
of used to it when I shook your hand and
met you you stood up as you were doing
it like staying careful all right here's
uh Kristen Baker says will Crowder's
company pay his creators guaranteed big
money regardless of the revenues they
bring in while they let their freak flag
fly time out I don't agree with the
premise nobody said it was regardless of
revenues you bring in it just said it
could not be tied to Big Tech
monetization and being on these
platforms if you're bringing in five
subscribers versus 500 000 that's a much
different thing yeah and sponsors versus
no sponsors that's a much different
thing nobody said that they couldn't
make money and nobody said Stephen had
to be given a guarantee production
contract no matter what money he brought
in they were completely and conveniently
leaving that off of the table and saying
this is a lot of money and if you lose
anything that's not going to happen to a
REV spot with upside right again this is
what happens in entertainment Street
every time whether it's abandoned a
venue right you do you do a minimum
guarantee which is going to be lower
which I'm going to get your risk or you
get the gate you do a REV split with
upside you see any upside there
is there anything is there any portion
there that says by the way if you
actually do have the 300 but which is
well over 300 000 people who said we're
going to be in Mud Club if you actually
do uh hit that you okay get to share in
this is there an upside down negative
it's 100 ownership and by the way
they're the only ones who demanded 100
merge Revenue that's that's not even
standard so 100 of merch hey you can do
the math right now you just saw the
sponsors sorry you just saw the live
numbers yeah that's what sponsors know
about how much can you guess can be
generated from a single sponsor with the
kind of numbers you know if you're doing
1.71.99 per show for 35 minutes what's
the what's the standard rate it's like
the point is it's a lawn yeah you don't
have to ask yeah but the point is 100
sponsors 100 subscribers 100 of merch
Revenue zero upside but 110 penalty
that's very different the premium Brands
charge like a 40 CPM yeah yeah and
that's and then what we found out 10
years ago was their view numbers were
inflated because they were buying the
rights to garbage Network traffic views
that don't matter and claiming it was a
premium view so you you know that what
I'm talking about yeah you know it's a
problem in our industry right and you
know that then sponsors get changed I
think it's fraud yeah and you know that
it happens right yeah yeah so this was a
big problem sponsors were like the
return Isn't there and they're wondering
why they start laying all these people
off from these digital media companies
it's like look man yeah if the sponsor
thinks they're buying gold standard view
but for every one for every 10 views one
is gold standard and nine is like
clickbait garbage right they're they're
wasting money and I think it's right but
there must be some concerns who are
focusing on quality over quantity right
you want one punch knockout power you
don't want to all some people can be
volume punchers some people can be power
Raiders they need to be able to allow
for both that's all we got a very we got
a very important one uh I got we gotta
remember uh Northern Liberty Group says
can Steven just say one good thing about
Canada I'll take Alberta or anything
they're real conservatives and Patriots
up here and we did have a rebellion
against the Brits it just failed that's
a big ask a lot now it is but I will say
this a lot of people don't know Bagels
came through Montreal first really
we're from but no yeah I'm not saying
it's original but I'm saying I came
through Montreal as opposed to New York
if not from Montreal there would be no
Bagels in North America well that would
be better it's our French Connection
yeah no I will say this restaurant at
best restaurants in the world in
Montreal probably uh pounds per pound
and there are a lot of great Canadians
uh we could probably get uncensored
version it'll be boring here but if you
look at the Quebec separatism a lot of
that is very similar to the taxation
without representation and a rugged sort
of individualistic Spirit but then they
also want to have the language police
the spaghetti you know spaghetti game
this is about a restaurant or a diner
yeah it was an Italian restaurant and
spaghetti was spaghetti and the language
police said wasn't in French that's not
French it's Carlos or like it's Italian
like we don't care spell it spaghetti
with an E yes they they said put spin in
there but there's no French for it and
they're like it doesn't matter you have
to have have it in French it was a
language police by the way also a lot of
French Canadians horribly have you have
you seen the skit the language police
skit that went viral it's two guys are
like an alley and they're like talking
and the cops walk up and they're like
hey what are you doing and they're like
what like hands against what they're
speaking French they're like you know
against the wall what I reckon it's it
and you know I don't expect you to be
trilingual no but uh they they put the
guys up against them and then they're
frisking them and then he's like he
pulls out a bag of weed and goes sorry
and he puts it back and then he keeps
going and he goes what's this and he
pulls out an English dictionary
that's not mine I swear that sounds
about right you know it's funny actually
like you talk about like no I do speak
friendships actually I learned to to
read and write uh French first I spoke
both they thought I was learning
disabled
they thought I was an idiot up until the
fourth grade uh because I had to do if
the rule in Canada and it comes from
something called Pure land which means
pure wool where they want pure French
European blood they don't necessarily do
it anymore and end up backfiring because
a bunch of Haitians and Vietnamese would
come in because you know I speak French
and they were like ah Carlos now we have
all the they're about not European
French they're the black from Haiti so
they changed their laws but the issue is
if you have one parent born in Quebec
whether they're English or not you have
to go to French immersion schools so it
wasn't that I was that dumb it's that I
was having to learn geography history
math in French and was falling behind
and when they finally threw a loophole
said hey if you do it as a temporary
resident because your dad's American
this principal really did probably save
my educational career in grade school
fourth grade they switched me to English
and then you know I made it to like a B
minus student like which means that
which means that I won't be a genius but
I won't be a mass shooter I'm right in
the middle of the pack you never hear
the guy he was all right we'll try and
grab some more Super chats we have this
one from Jeremy Higgins Jordan
Peterson's daughter made a video today
talking about negotiating her father's
contract with daily wire she said the
wire only owns the content on the site
for the length of the time of the
contract and afterward it returns to
Jordan I believe that sounds incorrect
I don't know I don't know I do know that
Jeremy said these are the terms of
everyone and I do know what's in that
contract and I do know they wouldn't
change it Jeremy said if we paid to
produce it we own it that would mean
that if they don't produce it I produce
it yeah it's a licensing agreement all
of the costs if I were an employee if
that's a salary sure but if all if it's
my product just try something does
TriStar own uh I don't know if home
alone I know Home Alone was Colombia and
someone else does TriStar own Colombia's
portion of that if they both come in
this production you know this right in
the entertainment industry it's very
very common for production houses to
come together does one get to say no we
own it no at that point afterwards it
switches maybe you have an agreement and
we by the way that's something that
we've worked into every contract that
we've done so I don't know this is a
very very important Jeremy mentioned
that everyone has different contracts
okay this is very important from Daniel
Martin he did say though this these
terms the big Tech terms right again it
was this is just these are demanded of
all creators he said that so so uh just
very important here Daniel Mark says
Stephen Crowder is the chaotic a good
high Charisma Barbarian in Dungeons and
Dragons you see some charismatic that's
nice
good for sure is that guy likes like
Robin Hood oh willing to like evil laws
willing to for you know forego evil laws
for the betterment I like the analogy of
rabbit because people think Robinhood
was a socialist no Robin Hood was
stealing for the people who over taxed
yeah back to the people yes you don't
strike me as a barbarian though uh you
know it depends on what I have maybe a
barbarian maybe what I have for dinner
loud mouth like in the front lines like
I'm gonna make noise to get it done no
I'm kind of a reluctant we prayed a lot
about this before we went down this road
like it was it was agonizing like just
make you sick kind of decisions because
of course you don't you don't want to
have to do this charismatic maybe you're
a paladin except that for the chaos
paladins generally are lawful but uh I
don't know I'm just talking about video
games
[Laughter]
about the moment Ian became self-aware
let me read this one from uh Mason's
Mama Tim is not asking the hard
questions Crowder lacks Integrity name
one Creator Crowder launched he has done
the exact opposite not gay Jared Sven
yeah they were on the show early on
we've had plenty of people who work on
the show and then move on
that happens Acro that happens across
the board I mean I'm not again you don't
have I used to we used to talk about
this we used to have pride in like this
super super high retention rate where no
one would leave but then we realized
that like people sometimes it doesn't
it's just not always the right fit and
people can go on and do something that
they're more happy with
um again we did a whole send-off with
knockajo we've had other people too
who've been on sometimes it's amicable
sometimes it's not sometimes those are
issues but not gauger's case the guy
left and I wish the guy the best he
tweeted it out so again this is the
problem right this is this is the
problem with people gaslighting it's
attacking of the left and there's going
to be four on one it's going to happen
no matter what I'm I'm calling it now
just like I called what was about to
happen and they're going to shift the
narrative to something else and they're
going to rope other people in and this
is why people don't speak out it's why
good people don't run for office think
about the stormy Daniel which by the way
I have no idea with Donald Trump but so
many people came out in so many stories
that were proven verifiably false it's
slinging mud it's personal it's not what
you hear me do it's this can all end we
all just pledge we're not going to do
the enforcement of Big Ten no one is
perfect at least about me at 9 10 I
launched a poll at uh eight o'clock I
launched a poll what time is it
right now it's crazy right uh who is
Right 36 minutes ago 62 000 votes
Crowder 63 daily wire 17 with 20
abstaining from the vote how long ago
was that this was uh 36 minutes ago with
62 421 votes I abstain pretty good
example so I don't think anyone's right
no that's the thing I mean there are
genuinely a lot of people who are like
you know they may not like what the
daily wire is doing but they like that
it's a cultural force in the other
direction do we need you know we need
both I do think we need these these
monolithic centralized systems in
coordinates with decentralized content
creators and eventually they'll start
licensing work and stuff and I
understand just don't say you're
fighting big Tech but you made a good
point uh Gerald about not you I'm
talking about people in 10 years it
should be solidified that there's no
competition and then they go the other
direction let me read this one because I
have to agree kid truck says don't give
money often but the quote we know what's
in the box killed me nearly choked on my
coffee a Crowder mug hope eventually the
hostilities can settle and ladder with
Crowder can show that standing on
principle can be profitable
the what's in the box was was I wrote I
wrote down the time Johnny boy that you
met downstairs now yeah uh there were
that was this well that was the hardest
I'd ever seen him laugh this that one's
the second artist
the second artist the second artist
again I'm not until but when Ben was
saying like you know Stephen Crowder
betrayed and he's a piece of and
all of a sudden like
and I have to tell you about Birch gold
he was laughing so hard when that
happened it was the Box comment that was
the second heart I'm like John what are
you laughing at he's like they had to do
live reads
um and like during the during the rants
yeah and there's nothing wrong again
there's nothing wrong with people who do
radio on TV right yeah and doodle
there's another but again you know
that's not I can't do four or five
commercials the way we do them each day
whether it's a good ranch or commercial
whether it's a whole film series you
know Walter we've done a parody of every
major horror film and it's you know
horror films don't work when you have a
wall through we can't do that and do it
five times a day and it fell into fears
like look we just we're just saying hey
more people pay far far more for one
spot just let us keep doing the sketches
the kind of material that people have
invested in and it's this is the model
well there needs to be no I'm not saying
that can't be a model though you can't
enforce big Tech I'm saying that there
can't only be one model for everyone
because we're not all that way and then
we about how the power that
Hollywood has because they allow
creatives the ability to be creative and
it really is look there is more at
divert and I'm just talking about
diversity as far as you know hitting the
right demographics I'm talking about
people doing different kinds of content
we're the only ones doing what we do and
I would love to see 10 more people doing
it and I see it as a huge win that Ben
was streaming on on Rumble today huge
um and I would if he comes over on
Rumble and by the way not just Rumble
but do both and just cleans our clock I
would I hope there's 10 more of them and
10 more of me
I'm glad to see it and I I still would
love to just don't say you're fighting
big Tech when you're enforcing big Tech
by mandate that's David
David Minier says I'm happy to spend 100
to tell Crowder he's a whiny baby daily
wire won this fight wasn't even close
okay you spent a hundred dollars yeah
yeah and then you made that money yes
that's a win good for you 75 of it or
something
seventy dollars YouTube Took 30. good
for you more or more you take a lot from
the super chats so that should change
too with these platforms all the revenue
all the super chat revenues directly to
you you know when I read the one word
said I'm asking not asking hard
questions I'm not here to to ignore
people who have criticisms and want
their voices to be heard um I wanna I
wanna make sure this is a substantive
conversation and I read if people are
happy or unhappy sure Thomas says Brett
Cooper the youngest employee said she
doesn't have the demonetization
penalties it seems to invalidate
Crowder's Point wakanda said that she
recognized the Clauses in her own
contract and Jeremy said that they are
in the contract and this is the one
thing they've never addressed it Beyond
well we have to make money but again how
are you making money off of some
penalizing someone being demonetized
when they haven't been monetized for
years when they come in so it'd be one
thing if everyone said it they said at
the top no this is for everybody Candace
said I recognize those contracts those
Clauses in the contract Brett Cooper
saying it's not if that's the case great
but that was a sticking point here that
was never there was no offer after that
and it just if someone said hey sure we
can change this great that's not what we
said yeah and you saw the transcript you
know it wasn't set you know it was this
is how we do it did you guys have um
access to all your mug Club subscribers
and like the number of them and all that
before you went into talks did you have
that data because I would have based my
entire contract off of that not how long
are you going to be monetized that's our
biggest that was our biggest problem was
that we we didn't have a real good way
that's why we had to launch mug Club
forever is to make sure that we had
everybody who wanted to it was in mug
club or wanted to sign up for it and we
could reach out to those people it's
industry standard where they don't tell
you and they don't even necessarily have
to tell you your number it doesn't have
to be
um but that's why I showed you know um
Tim some numbers that are off the Record
where you can do an estimate and yeah
absolute basement Baseline minimum is
yeah that's because Blaze had to on the
contract with blaze said they're gonna
keep that data and so only they knew is
that what well I can address that we're
not going to address necessarily
specific terms that were in that
contract because if you sign in on if
you sign something that says you want to
talk about it right it don't yeah it's
not the case of the term exactly right
so I'll make the claims it looks that
happened I don't know uh well you know
you can enter in your email mug clever
so we don't lose touch with you but we
had a good idea based on
Gerald you can I think this is the thing
right this is the problem with contracts
and I understand there's a big
difference between an NDA and you're
asking it is I will say this it is
industry standard I don't know of any
except for you know Rumble tweeted that
out I don't know how it works with
locals where they said you you I think
they said if you get generate
subscribers you can take your
subscribers they're yours to begin with
they're never the companies uh from what
I understand there uh but industry
standard is it's very it's opaque by
Design yeah yeah I think the only the
only company that can actually offer the
deal that you keep your members is
Rumble yeah yeah so uh I think you know
rumble's doing a bunch of deals with
people and I'm pretty sure those deals
are while we have you signed the revenue
comes to us when the term ends the
membership revenue is yours yeah it's
it's a part of your account that you own
and we've no longer licensed it
for these other companies there's no way
to effectively take a portion of your
members and put them on a different
website right yeah well that's also what
you're doing with this sort of
decentralized tool that you're
discussing right sort of solves that
problem a little bit Yeah the front end
part of it like rumbles the great thing
is it's a back-end service where it
hosts like daily wire I don't think they
have a host do they host their own data
you guys don't know I don't know yeah so
that's challenging if you're not if
you're just a front-end facility that
you're just kind of making money off the
personalities themselves not the actual
data but if you control the data then
you can give it back to people and this
I want to try just read as many as we
can uh we the people says I ABS I was
abstain in the poll earlier but the
second uh second half I voted now in
favor of Stephen Crowder fight back yeah
so this is interesting uh when the story
first broke we did a poll
85 percent Crowder is Right very small
percentage in favor of the daily wire we
didn't have the abstain in It Candace
Owens comes on the show it then dropped
down to like 55 to 60 Crowder is Right
40 or so percent daily wire is right we
did the show today obviously you guys
erected a lot of your fans to the show
so there's a big swing in your favor but
the second poll more dramatically swung
in your face well so did the most yeah
the biggest most powerful conservative
Network in the world according to how
they you know their press releases daily
wear I would assume that when their
people come on it would be the same
thing I shouldn't even here's the thing
here's the I shouldn't even be in the
same ballpark well you guys are saying
like Hey how do you think like you know
I'm I'm coming I'm a bum these other
when we're talking about VidCon they're
just worse bums in other words there's
such a dearth of creative content out
there that I'm even within Striking
Distance with no seed money certainly
not multi-millionaires or billionaires
front loading it it shouldn't even be
close and I can tell you now live number
hey Tim let me ask you this what's the
toughest number to cheat when you're
talking about like people adding people
oh you can't you can't cheat the lot
look when it comes to like uh uh you
could buy a YouTube video in fact anyone
can advertise any YouTube video right
you can go on Google ads take a video
from some random little kid pay for a
hundred thousand ten thousand views if
you want and that kid will have no idea
it happened
that would be a great gift I mean it's a
curse no I mean it's a Make-A-Wish
no but uh yeah yeah you know and we used
to we used to do that of course like
where you could run videos just through
Google AdSense right we've been barred
for a very long time from doing that and
I want to be clear I have no problem
none whatsoever with people advertising
I think I want more conservatives to
have advertising budgets because I want
us to out fight the left I have no
problem with people choosing and it's a
strategy to be monetized on YouTube I
think at a certain point when you look
at the advertiser guidelines which are
very different from the content
guidelines they include you could be
demonetized for controversial topics
sensitive issues that's a re I don't
even want to say it's a slippery slope
they've already covered everything under
that with their umbrella don't have a
problem with someone making that
decision I only have a problem when you
tell people that you are fighting back
and they are expecting it and investing
and you're not and you're demanding that
everybody else do it the same way as you
do there's only one side demanding that
we get rid of that I'll go on a press
tour for all these companies you I mean
it get rid of the punitive mandates
against conservative content creators
period as a matter of policy we're done
here forever
David Casada says I'm so exciting chats
trying to find a good question like
there's always some big something that's
there either the payment services with I
mean we got parallel economy which is
like Dan bongino's new payment Service
Company it's probably better than PayPal
and stripe I don't know if it's better
than stripe I don't know
um yeah if you get pissed off I want to
have the creators of stripe on the show
come on guys and let's talk about I got
I want to read these these two David
says I'm so glad Steven came out about
this because many leaders in the church
use and abuse other Christians they try
to use the term use them they try to use
them as volunteers then they offer super
low tiered payment options
a big problem too is there's a huge
unlike the left there's far too much
influence from non-profits on the
conservative side and a lot of these
this is another big part a part of big
con that we haven't even gotten into you
have a lot of these companies and this
is not I'm not saying daily daily wire
again there are a lot of companies where
they have a non-profit wing and we all
know there's a big difference between a
501c3 and a 501c4 and the audits that
have taken place because what happens is
the non-profit money of donors go in
there but then that's used in some way
to help generate content where they
collect the profit and yeah it does
happen in churches Gerald you know that
too
um where it's like it's non-profit
unfortunately someone is profiting at
some point so we do need to uncal we
need to uncouple we need to divest from
this undue influence of not of just
non-profits and we need to divest from
doing big text bidding here's here's one
from the new future from two copper says
I am a daily wire subscriber and I was
under the impression that my money was
helping to protect their message from
the predation of big Tech sensors as a
subscriber my trust was what was
betrayed
that's an interesting point um the one
thing I brought to people is like look
whether you agree or disagree with crowd
if there's a question of why penalize
someone for losing YouTube for for using
YouTube access when the goal is to build
a subscription business exactly at some
point at some point that should be the
goal does Netflix say to their show
creators if your show gets pulled from
YouTube we're cutting your fees despite
the fact we charge 10 bucks a month for
them to watch it on Netflix do you think
Netflix charges Winona Ryder if the
stranger things Premiere doesn't do well
again that's that's impermissible it's
not even legal in the entertainment
industry how can you be how can you run
a business and not incur any risk that
is income it's coming upon you where
it's like what should we take the risk
yes yes you're running the business
that's what being a business owner is
right you sink or swim you eat what you
kill yes not the CR not the not the
employee or in the case of an actual
independent production house you don't
penalize them for something that they
weren't making in the first place yes
you do incur some risk and in this
scenario it was a no risk situation why
would you why would you build it this
way right we've talked about this like
you built your career on YouTube is the
argument that people use right last
three years unmonetized it's like yes
we're trying to use we're trying to
speak the most truth to the greatest
number of people possible it's not we
can't just all have behind the paywall
honest conversations right because then
you don't affect people at the biggest
possible you know tech company out there
so do that but don't go so far as to
play by this additional set of rules
that really restricts what you're able
to say creators yeah we have um we have
only like one other real show it's him
cast right uh like live shot I'm saying
tails in the inverted World exists Jane
Cashman does amazing writing work but we
have pop culture Crisis 3 P.M Monday
through Friday I believe Brett uh
dasovich and Mary Morgan host the show
it is a very very similar format to this
except they have money guns when you
Super Chat money shoots in the air and
then every hundred thousand super chats
if the sirens go off and the money
sprays like crazy that's why I signed a
waiver that was very lengthy it's very
dangerous but um we I have no contractor
policy with them about suspension or
Banning if if they got pulled from
YouTube we'd be like I guess you're on I
guess you're on Rumble yeah and like
there's no you'd be fine with it there's
nothing wrong with choosing to be
monetized there's nothing wrong with you
making that choice or any other Creator
out there making that choice with
somebody enforcing it I'm saying like I
have no policy for that I'm not right
their pay doesn't change yeah the
structures like we we are investing in
the creation of this show and we've got
it it's going to take the form that it
has to take uh obviously they're better
off on YouTube in terms of growth but uh
sure we're we're also we got them on
Apple and Spotify and Google and all the
podcast platforms and I'd actually
rather grow that market than YouTube I
don't care about YouTube you know I
agree podcast way better that's when I
get excited too like when our numbers
switched from uh the vast majority on
YouTube you know to it's splitting and
then to the point where it tipped and
rumbles favor you know I come out and
when they tell me that when we're doing
I get really excited you know when we do
those like the 300 I think it was was it
350 it was like three before the servers
crashed and rumble's not a perfect
company level but we don't like
strengthen the server so like yeah we
got it like I don't think you fully got
it uh but um that was more exciting than
having whatever we had half a million
600 000 on YouTube I get that you want
to hit critical mass on YouTube but it
is exciting to we've talked about this
for years when you're at a point where
you can actually be a brother in arms
brother sister Z in arms
um with people who are flipping it to
the French government with people who
are saying no we practice what we preach
not saying only be on Rumble but isn't
that exciting that there is at least
some kind of viable alternative where
you can get enough views now that you
can make a living that's a big
development and that's also proof of
Concepts that we don't have to do
business the way that people in the big
con side say is a requirement at some
point I'm gonna have to pee I'm gonna
read uh just two more two more Super
chats floating eyeball all right first
game over says I'm canceling my timcast
subscription for the CNN talking to
Biden level of softballing oh come on no
that's fine um look if if what hard
question did we Dodge well I mean what
did you not ask us that people were
talking about but yeah about this topic
I mean I don't know I think I've said it
over and over again that I ideologically
agree with Stephen uh I disagree
tactically to a certain extent like the
recording of the phone call yeah but
yeah
am I going to scold you on the show and
be like how dare you Stephen or am I
going to be like tell me why you did it
well no I understand like you said they
say betraying a friend I say the
Betrayal first off has been taking place
for years to betraying the movement the
people who support you and invest you
the first portrayal in the sequence of
events was the term sheet the term sheet
and yeah what you saw now with going
after Talent right create behind the
scenes poaching people I can only show
you one I could tell you there's a lot
more but that guy said it's okay to show
it hopefully that provides a little bit
more I think we had a respectful and
cordial discussion I think some people
are asking if it was the agent or you
that counter offered that's what people
are asking so they went
from my understanding what the agent is
they said okay here's a number and this
is 100 of everything and uh my agent was
unbelievable he's just again he's left
the big agencies he's gay he's Latino
and he's to the right of Attila the Hun
he's Cuban he also doesn't like Puerto
Ricans but that's all they have to ask
about because it's hilarious because he
can get away with it
um where he said well if you want 100 of
everything here you go Jeremy said right
we started low we would have gone a lot
higher this is Contracting if you're
talking about the money part he said if
you 100 everything this is the number
it's higher but these are the
non-starters we were very clear these
are the non-starters there was never
anything suggested that got rid of the
non-starters and that's the part where
you start to lose faith and I frankly to
my Everlasting shame felt like oh well
you know there's no hope here if this is
these are the non-stars and this is in
every Clause we'll grab one more Super
Chat so then uh Steven go urinate Peter
Piper says I agree with everything
Crowder is saying about the offer being
bad how does he justify this is good for
conservatism by creating schisms it's
like he is throwing out the baby with
the bath water changed my mind I can I
would have agreed
three years ago maybe yeah or this has
been happening for a long time when you
sit down and they go nope nope this is
how it has to be at a certain point do I
believe that the conservative movement
is better off now when you know and you
see behind the curtain that these are
the kinds of terms that cannot be
changed by their own words to all major
content creators out there no I wouldn't
have been able to create what I've
created you know Tim that you wouldn't
have been able to have created what you
have created under these kinds of terms
and no one else will be able to if it
continues this way we will continue to
lose and the public we'll be surprised
and dumbfounded how we snatch defeat
from the jaws of Victory well the last
thing I'll say is I had conversation
with the daily wire and ultimately we
decided it wasn't going to work the
difference between my Approach and your
approach is that I just said look I'm
gonna go build my own thing best of luck
I appreciate the work you do I don't
wouldn't want to do business in the way
you do it but that's your business not
mine and that's all I did you know what
I mean yeah and I understand it uh at a
certain point it's like you can move on
and just tilt the rearview mirror away
to the wreckage I'm not saying that
that's the same case with you I don't
know what the terms are for you but in
this case based on what you see there
it's fundamentally immoral and I think
again who does it hurt hurts the
sponsors it hurts the investors it hurts
the viewers and it hurts the creators
and that ultimately hurts the country
and hurts the movement if you say you're
fighting big Tech fight Let's uh
let's do this I'll I'll talk to you guys
a little bit more about uh some of the
offers that we've received and how they
work and why they don't play out I'll
get a little bit more into the um the
terms I was offered by various companies
we'll explain that in the members only
show so go to timcast.com if you aren't
already click the join us button sign up
we're gonna have an uncensored members
only show I'll talk a little bit more
about the inner workings of the deals
and I'll talk as much as I can about
what I've been offered and why I said no
and then I'll ask Stephen how he really
feels so again go to timcast.com become
a member they can go to Louisville
February 10th uh and uh you know but
it'll all be based on jokes
I'll say this follow the show you can
follow the show at timcast.com you can
follow me at timcast again timcast.com
for the uncensored show I'll post the
link on YouTube after the show reps do
you guys want to promote anything shut
anything out before you before you go uh
no I mean the thing is we're doing I
will say the owner of this guy he owns
like Louisville uh Oklahoma uh City I
think and a bunch of comedy clubs you
know because they booked six months out
he actually made it possible where I was
able to buy the headliner for that week
and like pay his fee to be able to do
this because you know this all kind of
happened last minute so uh yeah a lot of
credit.com tour where uh you know an
hour and a half every night uncensored
we'll just keep adding shows doing
smaller venues so we can't do the
theaters until probably next quarter but
it's always fun and I think the people
who watch this know you better than they
know me anyway louder with Crowder is
your show Stephen Crowder on YouTube at
s Crowder on Twitter Gerald do you want
to shout out any socials or G Morgan Jr
these very very milk toast he's very
kind if he gets mad it's it's a little
upset mildly portrait yeah okay
is that your Twitter account what was
that was that again at gmorganjr thank
you guys so much for coming and having a
cordial respectful dialogue and
discussion here in the beginning of this
broadcast I told everyone about my new
Venture and website I'm the real og.com
and as soon as I did my web guy told me
we were DDOS yeah yes don't worry you
could have your Taco Bell and we won't
know anything about it but we were
ddosed and the website was down in the
beginning of this broadcast it is now
back up uh I'm the real og.com and I'm
gonna miss you guys this was a fun crazy
last show uh I'm gonna be doing meetups
lots of fun exciting projects uh first
dibs are going to be members on Lucan
sensor.com best way to get in touch with
me Lucan censored.com see you there and
uh holy cow
this was fun I'm going to be in Florida
for a while and uh you guys keep up the
great work Ian real quick I want to give
a shout out to Mark Dice and just
apologize because I know uh I know Mark
he super chatted a bunch YouTube deleted
the first hour of super chats because
that's what they do what at a certain we
get too many oh at a certain portion it
just starts they just start disappearing
yeah and then there's one one thing we
can do and we can we can go into the
back end and try and start scrolling
through and pulling them back up but the
it's it's difficult what we need to do
especially as we get into the new studio
space look we don't even have a
headphone dial like like volume control
for the guests it's just all done by
Kellen or Sergio whoever's at the
command like control so we like we're
trying to continually up and improve get
to that point one thing we're going to
do is we're going to have super chats
grabbed during the show so we don't miss
anything especially big ones but uh Mark
uh shout out and apologies you know uh
he I mean I I can't that's why I brought
up his Super Chat because I saw the
super chats at the beginning and I
mentioned his super chat so he got his
money's worth Mark you got it I
mentioned it I talked about it in some
ways but um again thank you guys so much
for dealing with me and having me here I
really appreciate it yeah it'll sink in
after you leave how sad it is that
you're gone but I'm happy that you're
doing what you love you know moving on I
appreciate it um thank you Gerald great
to see you man yeah Stephen always a
pleasure I think he's in the bathroom
what you guys pull up mug Club
forever.com yeah so again this is not an
information site this isn't like hey
stay up to date on what's going on it's
if you want to join Mud Club or you're a
member of Mud Club already mugclub
forever.com and your email address you
will not get any emails other than one
that says here's what we're doing and
here's how to sign up thanks again for
coming guys yeah I miss it um we're
still going thanks uh again I'm Kellen
PDL thanks guys for having me uh Gerald
Steven I've been watching you guys for
Years love what you guys do keep
fighting the good fight
and Luke I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
missing you I remember that for like one
of the first days I started here like
hey we have to get the stuff out of the
attic Luke's coming I'm like oh boy here
we go and it seems like yesterday and
you're already leaving for sunny Miami
so time flies by when you're talking
about the parks department being
horrible along with the IRS
and the FBI and all these other Federal
institutions Maxwell came out today we
might might hopefully
after show all right uh everybody head
over to timcast.com for the members only
show we will see you all there